Lav is included in the defendant's
initial disclosures as
[Music]
an also go yeah there's no reason for
him to protected I'm glad that they
protected this person's identity they
could really be in a lot of trouble this
person's apparently been threatened
whoever this person is could have been
in a lot of trouble if their identity
was exposed
[Music]
now good times why is he so racist this.
I don't know why he keeps pointing out
that this judge is from Puerto Rico.
Puerto Ricans are Americans, right? He's
like, "Oh, that's what is He's He's
literally like one of the androids from
um from Westworld." Okay. He sees a
screenshot of somebody asking for
explicit consent. He's like, "Doesn't
look like anything to me. It's a
conspiracy." What? I have no idea what's
going on here. Too much. Okay. If you're
a DGer, you have to look at this silence
and be like, "Wait, I thought we were
winning, buddy. Buddy, we were winning.
I thought we were Aren't we doing good?
I thought we were doing so good. Wait,
why are you Why are you totally silent
right
now?
Well,
well,
well, let's check it out. Let's see what
he had to say. 10 pager. I do want to
get to the part cuz I know cuz people
already linked me that he reacted to my
stream and he got so hilariously ass mad
at my stream that I had to I was like,
dude, it's so funny how angry he's just
like seething on the stream and I'm like
dying laughing. I'm dying laughing while
I can hear myself dying laughing and
watching him see about it. Like I can
hear my laugh
going. I'm actually laughing in the room
while he's just seething on the stream.
It was very goofy. Okay, I'll see if I
can recreate their balls to get this out
tonight. Okay.
Defendant Steven Bunnel the second is a
prominent online content creator and
live stream with over 840,000 followers.
Since the initiation of his lawsuit,
defendant has repeatedly discussed and
published details of the litigation on
his public platforms. You know, he
wanted to pause and go, "Hold
on,
842,000. Stop taking inches off my
Miss, what's the
Joanne? Joanne. Oh, the I I got lost the
last name. God damn it. God damn it.
Sorry. I'm I'm normally getting by now,
but I had to come back and stream for
you guys. Okay. Why can't I remember her
name? Female council for
Pixie. God, never mind. And home
addresses of council and even someone's
excuse me, all of this information is
public. It's literally at the end of all
of your
the names and home address. What home?
Yeah, it's just normally like hold on
the
names. Okay, the name of the leader of
Israel is public, but if it's, you
know, if it's Mr. Nasra,
um, RIP, okay, if it's if it's Nasra
talking about Benjamin Netanyahu,
talking about how evil Israel is is, is
a little different than just like that
name being public.
Okay, that's like a that's a goofy
little analogy, but I'm just saying that
obviously even if herit was public.
Okay, even if herit was public, I'll
move my over. Yeah, even if your was
public, obviously Destiny is like
railing on these people and saying that
they're borderline like breaking the law
to go after him maliciously, right?
Also, this is not quite working
correctly. That back just a little bit
like that. Okay, you're ah I've still
got little holes. I've got little holes.
Whatever. Oh, that's too much. I don't
like it. Hold
on. Got to turn that back down. Even if
we get a little bit of the rim going.
Yeah, that's better. That's better.
That's
better. Wait, what are you covering
right? What are you covering right now?
Wait, are can you not see the screen?
I'm covering Destiny's reaction to those
documents Pixie just
filed. Yeah, exactly. Dopey Wednesday.
It's like he's literally doing it while
talking about how these people are
trying to him in front of people who are
like loyal to him completely. Which by
the way, I'm just very embarrassed for a
lot of the names I see in this chat. Uh
I mean chiefly right now, Marquette
Kurtka, that's pretty embarrassing. Um
but like these people are so We'll just
get into like some of the arguments he
makes. you. I genuinely feel
like like sad for these people. Like
very
sad. Very very sad. Whatever the end of
your Am I Oh, hey Ry. Wow. Thanks for
the five gifted. Very cool. Very cool.
Very cool. Very cool. Is it illegal? Is
it illegal for me to show the to show
the public filings? Hello.
Uh no, it's not illegal. They're
actually saying they're actually
explicitly saying although this conduct
is not illegal, we would like a gag
order saying that he should not be able
to do this because we feel like he's
threatening the council here and other
people. Right.
That's actually the whole point of the
motion, Destiny. I don't know if you're
like totally behind, but that is
actually what the point of the motion is
right now is to say, "Hey, this person's
kind of unhinged, and we want you to to
use your power to make this illegal for
him to do." Mrs. Judge, Ms. or Mr. Yeah.
Miz judge Jacqueline Picara.
I don't I
what what does he expect him to do?
Uh magistrate. I don't believe this
protective was this protective order
going in front of the magistrate judge
or is this going in front of I thought I
saw Jaclyn Baker's name on the on the
proposed order. I think this is not as a
part of the preliminary injunction. I
think this is in the primary case.
Is 10 pages the limit or do they need to
ask for extra? No, 10 pages is your
ordinary limit, I think.
Jesus. Anyway, we could I doxed them.
Okay. And even he knows the definition
of doxing, too, which is Yeah. like
collecting this information in a place
and then using it for the purpose of
harassment. Like, okay,
I don't necessarily think it's wrong to
go over these without uh without
redacting, but if you're going to go
over and say that these people are like
evil, possibly, especially if you've got
a big enough audience, there's probably,
you know, as you get larger and your
audience is capable of more and more,
I'd get a little more worried about it,
right, with as you scale as a content
creator. Some of the discussions, he's
also made derogatory and intimidating
statements about the plane. He's super
highlighting. Well, it's just funny that
this whole time he's going to go through
and highlight the precise behavior that
they're pointing out and saying this is
what we think is bad. This is this is
why we think we need a projective order
and his entire stream is just doing
every behavior every type of behavior
that they suggest is like the reason
it's I don't know man it's
crazy I can make derogatory statements I
want. This is a free country baby
intimidating statements. What I what and
statements about the plaintiff her
council plaintiff's witnesses and her
perspect pro perspective
witnesses how bro you've already you
filed the lawsuit like what four months
ago and you're and you're looking at
pers so what I can't say anything bad
about everybody on planet
earth okay the funny thing here
is I have to keep going I shouldn't
pause too much but like the very funny
thing here is is obvious viously
um there's somebody very specific that
he's like threatened is me. Okay. And
he's going to make the simultaneous
argument. He's made this argument
multiple times that I have nothing to do
with the case. He has he doesn't think I
have anything to do with the case and
that threatening me has nothing to do
with the case. But also say that he has
tried to subpoena documents related to
me. So I don't know I don't know which
one is the I don't understand. Does
nobody in DGG chat ever point this out
to him that you're arguing both things
at the same time? You're like, I am
subpoenaing this person. This person is
doing a conspiracy against me. Also, I
can threaten them and they have no
connection to the case. Can both of
those things be
true? How does he make both of these
arguments at the same time? Because
everybody on the planet could be a
prospective witness. What does that even
mean? Okay. Damn. That's based. Okay.
Based base legal tactics. Okay.
Indeed, several witnesses, including
those that provided declarations in
support of plaintiff's motion for
learning injunction, have expressed fear
of being publicly targeted or doxed.
This is not a real thing for the Isn't
he just saying you're not related to the
suit Pixie filed? Yeah, but he knows
that's not
true. At bare minimum, at bare minimum,
uh, I am the person who told him about
the leaks in the first place and has
like the original time stamp on that and
the original logs on that and can tell
that story. And he knows that. He knows
that that is materially relevant to this
case, right? You don't even have to do a
lot of thinking to know that that's
materially relevant to the case. What do
we talk? What do you publicly targeted
by defendant and or his followers and
have indicated they're unwilling to
participate in discovery or testify
unless their identities remain
confidential? Oh my
god. What? I'm sorry, but like this is
we're in the big boy world now and we're
if you want to be a big boy and you want
to come and do court stuff, that's fine.
But we're going to move past the this is
my Twitter account and this is my Reddit
and now we're using our real life
identities because we're doing Oh, look.
Now he understands. Oh, look. Now, when
it's the big boy world and he wants
everybody's name on here, he understands
that a real life name and a pseudonym
aren't the same thing. But for some
reason, he believes people making posts
under the pseudonym count as legally
like doxing themselves somehow and he
should be able to use their legal names
now. I don't I again just all of the
people in DGG chat very embarrassing
lack of any IQ or you know personal
inside internal
monologue/ Chad can't talk about a
dinner bell anymore. A
wait can they not I feel like this is
like actually just indicative of a
dinner bell but I don't don't worry Ry
none of that was based on reality. I
didn't even respond to it. They're just
goofy people. They just try to say they
just try to say things that get under
your skin. Don't worry about it, buddy.
Doing a real life court case. All right.
You have to decide if you want to do big
boy things or if you want to on Twitter
or Substacks. You can't have it both
ways. You have to put your big boy pants
on and you got to go to court and you
have to say this is my name. This is
what I'm testifying to. That's what we
do here. Like Jesus
Christ. See plaintiff's declaration
attached here too as exhibit A. For this
reason, the witness declarations were
filed under seal based.
Okay. Plaintiff is requesting that the
court enter the narrowly tailored
proposed protective order attached to
his exhibit B to protect the integrity
of these proceedings to prevent a
chilling effect on evidence gathering
and testimony. Why don't you already
have
this? We're 4 months into the case. How
do you not already have
Um, yeah, I think I I do think that that
could be there, but unfortunately he's
continued to talk and say these things
long after the case was filed. Uh, hello
Ken the jelly man. He came back. I did
come back tonight actually. And I Isn't
it up that I have to lie to you guys so
meticulously that when I said I was
coming back and I promised I didn't come
back and tonight when I said I'm almost
certainly not coming back and then I
come back. Isn't that up? Isn't that up?
All of this by now. What do you like?
You haven't It's not like you're serving
discovery requests to us and those
people are denying things. Like what
the This order would apply equally to
all trial participants and serve to
protect to prevent further public
doxing, harassment, intimidation, and
misinformation without defense
continuous extrajudicial comments. I'm
reading the the I'm reading your
filings.
Oh, these would be um you accusing them
of perjuring themselves, them of taking
witnesses and making them lie. This
would be uh the conspiracy theories
you're like creating about me or Pixie
or whoever, right? He's not you're not
just reading the documents. You're not
just reading the documents. You're
adding a lot of editorialization and
you're straight up defaming people. Uh,
he's going to do it again because he's
once again emotionally dregulated and
asmad and he'll start making up like
insane skitso theories
again. But that's okay. Well, that's
okay for me. It's funny for me. Uh, I
don't know about him. He's He's kind of
losing it.
What on his Sorry, I should be clear. I
don't know if he's actually losing it. I
don't know if he's losing it or if he's
like giddy at
how like bad faith and he can be while
his entire audience like backs him up.
He's just like, "Dude, I'm I'm like
actually Trump. I can actually shoot
somebody on Fifth Avenue." Like, oh my
god, I can just say whatever the these
will believe me. Oh my god. Streaming
platforms over,000 like of materially
prejudicing this
proceeding. Relevant facts. Defendant
has publicly threatened physical harm to
individuals that have spoken out against
him and in support of plaintiff
plaintiff for just killing equipment. I
kill him if I could. I'd show up there
and do it. I do want somebody to kill.
Oh, we got the bull and
underline. Yeah, cuz you're directing
other people, which like but the entire
argument in here is like he he's like
directing his audience to harass people
and he's directing his audience to like
harm people and he's like immediately he
like highlights this and goes, "Oh, I
guess this is what's happening.
We got the bold and underline. These two
people, none of these people are
involved with this case. Why? I don't
understand why they keep they mentioned
like 15 different court docks. Sorry,
that was me. That was me.
Jesus. Um, again, I if I'm not involved
with the case. Okay, so there's Wait,
now I'm not involved with the case.
Okay, keep in mind he talks in this
stream and in multiple other streams
about actually having subpoenaed me.
So I how is he subpoenenaing me if I
have nothing to do with the case? Wasn't
that the whole reason that all of the
other testimony from those other people
had nothing to do like that shouldn't be
entered because it had nothing to do
with the case. So he'll argue that I
have nothing to do with the case. But
apparently he'll subpoena records about
me. I don't know what these are, by the
way. I have no idea. I've not heard
about this. I got no idea. Maybe I just
haven't checked my
mail. Maybe I'm getting these
individuals are potential witnesses.
Bro, what? It's like Agent
Smith.
What? How? The funniest part about this
is the next line. How do you not know if
they're a witness yet? What in this
action due to their knowledge of the
facts and related interactions with the
defendant? Indeed, Lav is included in
the defendant's initial disclosures as
an I'm sorry, that's the last time I do
that just in case anybody's trying to go
to sleep. But he literally listed Lav as
somebody who might have material
information to the case. Individual
likely to have discoverable information.
Hold. How does he explain that? Serve
her with a subpoena.
He's so
[Laughter]
stupid. It's literally his team has said
this person may have information related
to the case and that's a person he's
threatening and says he wants to kill.
He wants somebody to kill her. Why would
you don't give don't even make it. Also,
by the way, they publicly filed this
initially, which is funny enough. But
why are you then you don't even you
don't have to Oh, wait. Sorry. It's
Pixie team. It's Pixie team. Sir, that
other person was No, no, hold on. Defend
it. No, defend it. Is it says it's
Destiny's team. Maybe it is plaintiffs.
Maybe it's Pixie's team, but it looks
like it's Destiny's team. Hold on. That
right there. That says Destiny's team.
So, I That was how I read it. He's now
acting like it was Pixie's team, but I
thought it was Destiny. H
whatever. There's no way that's true,
right? That lab's in the Maybe this is a
mistype and it's in the plaintiff's
initial
disclosures. The defendant has tried to
do. This is so cringe. Doxing is not a
thing in in big boy world. People use
their real life. Wait, no, it is it is a
thing. Hold on. It is a thing if you're
trying to direct harassment with it,
right? It is. You can you can't sue
somebody. There's no law against doxing,
but there are laws against like
publishing somebody's information with
orders to like go hurt them. Absolutely.
There are names and they're real life
sometimes their home addresses, which
mine has been exposed multiple times. In
this court case, if you want to do real
life big boy things, then you have to do
real life big boy things. You don't get
Wait, but hold on now. Hold on. Now he's
arguing. Is he now arguing that we are
related? Cuz I didn't. He was just
arguing I'm not related. Where's the
real life big boy things that I'm doing
from this point in the I don't
understand. Do you see how he just
alternates between whether or not I'm
related or I'm unrelated? He can't seem
to decide. It's just whatever serves his
argument best in the moment. Get to use
a a Discord username and my address is
the Discord user.
Yeah, show up or off. What do you mean?
The defendant has tried to dox both
queen and Jess. These people aren't
parties to any of this case. They're not
parties to the case. Then why did you
just go on that rant about doxing and
it's big boy
world? Also, why are you trying to
subpoena people not party to the case?
See, also Google Drive and
Shamu Twitter. Those are just intent.
Thank you for the Twitter links. I can't
wait for the judge to be clicking these
in court.
What is this Google Drive link? Hold
on. He's very used to Oh, don't want to
click any of my Google Drive links on
stream. Call you requested does not
exist.
Uhoh. Okay.
There's a space in the URL. I could
probably go find out what it is, but I'm
good right now. The term dox or doxing
means to publicly identify or publish
private information about someone as a
form of harassment or revenge. Does it
count provided service to me at my home
address and my address is published or
what?
Okay. What was that
response? What was the response?
Wait, didn't he just get raped by
pulling up that tweet? It contradicts
what he just said. Well, that they're
not part of the case. Sorry. Wait, hold
on. BB Poison, what do you mean here?
I'll go back. What do you mean when he
pulls up the tweet? Who judge will be
clicking these in court?
I actually don't know what you mean, BB,
but doxing when they provided service to
me. My home address and my address is
published or
provided services to me and my home
address and my home address is
published.
Okay. Defendant regularly streams on
YouTube channel. The details of this
case included confidential details from
meet and confidential. What are you
talking about? We haven't decided
nothing that has been if anything has
been sealed or redacted. I haven't
discussed. I believe meet and confers
are supposed to actually based on the
rules for civil procedure. I believe
meet and confers like the the the
conference information that is supposed
to be remaining like not public. Uh
definitely settlement negotiations are
supposed to not be public. Uh like
pre-trial settlement negotiations those
should not be public. Those
things after plaintiff replied to the
opposition for to motion for preliminary
junction was filed. He streamed about
the filings, showing them on his screen,
reading excerpts aloud, and writing
vitriolic and defamatory commentary for
over an hour.
Sometime these are not just you're these
are court
sometime. These are not Was he drunk for
this stream? Gross.
Saying you're not involved in the case.
And I think the clip in the tweet was
trying to involve you in the case saying
I was amplifying from farm. These are
not confidential. You're these are court
filings. These are public filings. I'm
not Am I not allowed to read the public
filing? Also, I'm allowed to say
vitriolic. Well, defamatory is a
opinion. It's my court case. I'm I'm
allowed to say whatever the it's I have
a first amendment right.
Um, so the first amendment right is
going to be weighed against prejudicing
the case, whether you're actually
actively preventing witnesses from
coming forward. Unfortunately for
Destiny, he terrifies a lot of people.
Terrifies his ex-wife will never do
anything, right? And I I I don't even
blame her for that. She's like like he
is a terrifying person. Like he will go
after anybody and anybody with a career
on the internet wants nothing to do with
like making statements against him.
Yeah. So, obviously, if witnesses are
too scared to come forward, that is
prejudicing the the
trial. Does it matter if he does it or
Darius does? Well, I that's kind of how
he's trying to get around it. I feel
like they should probably I'm almost
positive they should try to
um subpoena like his communications with
Darius just because I have Darius
statements on like, oh, is this what we
were talking about? And then the the
messages to Wes all very concerning. Oh,
and Darius like trying to get Abby to
message Destiny about getting paid to
not test. That's weird. Or not sue him.
Very bizarre
stuff. This video has been viewed
120,000 times to date. In it, defendant
accuses plaintiff of extorting and
blackmailing him, of insane lies, of a
total lie. Okay. Is any of this illegal?
Okay. All right. In the same video,
defendant accuses plaintiff's witness,
Abby Mc. Thank you for redacting her
identity. Good job. Of lying and
perjury. He refers to the undersigned
council as disgusting. True. Oh, they're
personally offended. Get mad. Joanne, if
you're reading this, you are disgusting.
You are a disgusting, horrible person.
You are. I hope you know that. And I
feel that way personally about you. I'll
make a declaration to the court if I
need to as
well. Joanne Schlump Peters, that is the
the uh the council for Pixie, the
primary council for Pixie, I believe.
No, no, no, no. Joan Schlump Peters
Pixie's primary council. He refers to
the undersign council as disgusting and
repeatedly accuses the undersign council
of grabbing random people to perjure
themselves. That's a defamatory
statement. 100% that's a defamatory
statement. That is a thousand% a
defamatory statement. One that could be
extremely damaging to her. Defendant
accused Oh, he's not going to respond to
that one though. Council of bad faith
arguments, explicit lying, and abuse of
the court system.
Yes, you did this. You did all four of
those things. True. Respond. True and
true. So, you're continuing. Wait, wait,
wait. What about the perjuring thing? Do
you notice how he actually skips the
thing that he's going to have to
actually be on the on the hook for for
proving that? He just skip right by
that. He doesn't want to keep pressing
that one because now they've informed
him that, hey, we think that's
defamatory, right? But he's going to
he's just going to skip right by it.
He spends a full 30 minutes telling his
followers that plaintiff council has no
understanding of the federal rules
of they're so assigned. Why are they why
are they putting this in in any of these
filings? It has nothing to do with this
case. Wait, what? How? At what point is
it Destiny is gonna like it's gonna be
that they go to Google, they subpoena
Google and they actually get back that
he sent the Pixie video to like 12
different people and they have their IPs
and they can go and subpoena those
people and find out yeah they did find
the video and stuff and he's literally
going to see that evidence come down and
he's going to
go what does that have to do with this
case? That doesn't have anything to do
with this case. It's like at what at
what point the only context you know
this person in that you are currently
is in this case. At what point do we
reach the point of absurdity where you
say it has nothing to do with this case?
They're actually She's actually mad.
She's actually mad. Yes.
She's like ra Wait, does he actually use
soundboards a lot now? Did he Did he
have to copy my soundboard, too? That's
That's embarrassing, bro. Posting on the
filings. They have 10 pages. they have
10 pages to file for their client and
she's and Pixie's like can we include
this like no and then he said that I was
a he called me a dumb and he said I
didn't even know the federal rules of
civil
procedure defended accus I just want to
point out that it is a debate strategy
to only focus on like the weakest point
the other person makes and to just skip
over any intelligent or strong point
they make right like he does skip over
the perger themselves thing because In
previous videos, he's also pulled back
from that because obviously somebody
informed him saying that is bad. That's
an actual defamatory statement. You have
no proof of that. Please don't say that
again. So he skips right over that one,
right? And focuses on the other ones.
It's very funny. 30 minutes telling his
plaintiff council has no understanding
of the federal superure because they
allegedly did not adhere to proper
procedures by filing redacted
declarations of the witnesses along with
the motion to file under seal. The
unredacted versions defendant of course
is wrong since the court granted
plaintiff's motion to file under seal.
So this would be a bad faith argument.
It would be explicitly lying and it
would be abuse of the court system. I
like how they did all three right here.
My issue is not you filing things under
seal. And you know this because of our
own filings. The issue is you thinking
that you can file things under seal
while keeping those private from us.
You're not allowed to do that. Kind of
like how you I don't even know if that
was his whole argument the previous
time. I'm pretty sure that he said they
like they actually failed to do things
and the judge will throw them out or
something. Filed you. you. But he made
sure to back off that I ran this all by
Oh, I can't wait to see how he responds
to that. Actually, yes, if you remember
from earlier when we were reading this,
uh, they actually explicitly quote
Destiny when he says, "I run all
everything I say by my
council." I was like, "Dude, Andy's not
going to be happy about that one."
Andy's going to be like, "No, no, no,
no, no, no. Don't put your on me, bro."
That showed us a motion, asked us to
agree to it, and then you filed a
different one with the court. That's an
example of explicitly lying and abuse of
the court system.
Actually, I think that's probably more
just an example of bad faith. I don't
know if it's I don't think it's
explicitly lying or an abuse of the
court system. It's being dishonest and
it's bad faith for sure. You're saying
here's the thing we're going to do and
you file something else. That's
definitely bad faith. He actually missed
the one it actually was. Okay. Jesus.
That's fine.
Defendant of course is wrong. uh this
type of misinformation about the
litigation on his platform is rampant
and based on the thousands of comments
on the YouTube video is accepted as
gospel by his followers. Disturbingly
all of this extrajudicial commentary is
approved by defendants council. Oh, they
love throwing this one. I pass
everything that I Yeah. Well, you said
it. Wait, does he Dude, people pointing
this out, Alex Jones, right, or Carl
Jobs, these people who like kept whining
about their cases and actually sunk
themselves in court. It's so
funny. I don't know if that'll happen
here. I really don't know what the
outcome of this case will be, but it's
so funny that Destiny's managed to
create multiple additional motions that
he has to respond to because he can't
shut the cup up. I Dude, Andrew Breler
is a genius. Andrew Breler has like the
perfect money-making strategy. He's
like, "No, no, no. I'll totally help you
defame all of these people. I'll totally
help you defame all of these people."
Yeah. Yeah. we'll like we'll do this
whole thing and secretly he's like yeah
they're going to really complain about
this we're going to get like 80
different motions okay I get to run
counters to all of them I get to write
all of those counter arguments all of
those counter motions all of those
motions in opposition rather okay I'm
going to get so many buildable hours
he's just running a racket on like
destiny I publish by my lawyers first
when I made this comment when I say
publish by the way talking about the um
I think that initial me or whatever that
I did is that what he meant uh Not that
it's not like I script out all my live
streams and YouTube. I don't know what
he's saying. That's what he said. That's
absolut Oh my god. Somebody get me the
clip. He was like, "You think I just go
live without talking to my lawyers." He
had the whole thing where he's like, "I
write up I in the morning I get up and I
write notes to my lawyers about what
they should say back and then they tell
me like what I can say and then I go
live." Wasn't that like the whole thing
or am I hallucinating that? I'm almost
positive that he talked about how he
writes up the like summary of
information for his lawyers. He sends it
to them and then he talks about what he
he they tell him what he can talk about.
I'm almost positive this happened. They
know that. They're just But okay, good
one. That's not
dude. Oh, we'll see. I I might have time
with like Riyle after this. Maybe I'll
go and try to find some of these things
cuz holy sh Jesus. The defendant has
also told his followers.
Destiny, you said that about the
minifesto. Look at this.
[Laughter]
Dustin, you only said it about the mini
festo. Dustin, you already explained
this in that
video. H on Kiwi Farm. Are we just
linking? What the Bro, I told you they
were getting their arguments from Kiwi
Farm. Are they just straight linking to
the farms
now?
Hello. The defendant has told his
followers on Kiwi his followers on Kiwi
Farm. I Yeah, realistically I This is
clearly mistyped, right? What can you
do? What can you do? What can you do?
Not the first up from Pixie's legal team
on this filing. Unfortunately, the Kiwi
Farms are my followers. The Witness ABMC
is crazy and insane unhinged. He also
informed his message to the court. We
were not making serious accusations of
Andy running a racket. We were just
being facitious. Thank you. Um, yeah, I
was being facitious, but I'll just point
out that as Destiny points out, I'm not
like one of the parties in the case
right now. Um, I'm actually not
technically officially involved in the
case in in like any way. I I said I
would as I came on uh the stream and
said I told them I'd make a statement if
they could protect my legal identity cuz
I don't want my legal identity getting
exposed with this guy telling his
followers that they should be trying to
kill me. I just feel like that'd be
risky for me. Okay, that's what I said.
Um yeah, so but I would if they wanted
me to I would be officially involved if
they need that. That helps the case
community of the name of Abby MC's prior
boyfriend because it's public knowledge.
We've all They stream. They stream
together. We've all seen it. What
the
Again, if it's public knowledge, then I
I I'm sorry. You have to You're an
illegal case. You're the person
confirming this to other people. That's
you, buddy. When it gets filed under
sealed, that's
you. Oh my god, bro. I like how Tiny
thinks the judge cares where the
arguments came from. Sorry, Miss Pixie.
That argument came from Kiwi Farms. Jury
strike that from the record. Yes. Like,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Are you telling me that they
posted evidence of your wrongdoing on a
website called Kiwi Farms? Well, we
can't consider that evidence at all.
That's like that's that that's
disgusting, sir. Mr. Bennell, do are you
aware that you've been wronged horribly?
That you are actually the biggest victim
here? We should let you counters sue
her. Actually, Kiwi Farms disgusting,
bro.
POV, you're actually winning. POV,
you're totally actually winning right
now. I promise. I promise, guys. Guys,
POV, you're totally actually winning at
this exact moment in
time. The defendant has also publicly
doxed and attacked Lauren Hayden.
When did I dox her? I don't I can't dox
her. I don't even know where she lives.
Where the can I
I believe using the full name. Is Lauren
writing all of this? There's no way,
right? There's no way that this the
other lawyer from Puerto Rico would
would just hand over the docks to her,
right?
I just want to like is it this has to be
disturbing because we all like a lot of
us came from DG. This has to be
disturbing that he's actually like
descending. He's actually descending
into like some QAnon level thinking,
right? Like yeah, I don't know if he if
he got like high and booted the stream
up. I don't know. It's it's
crazy. Also, what were his just real
quick when he when he does talk about
like the the lawyer from Puerto Rico? He
keeps Puerto R this lawyer from Puerto
Rico. This lawyer from Puerto Rico is uh
is Tony Hinchcliffe writing his material
now or how did he react when Tony
Hinchcliffe made the the island of
garbage comments? Okay. Why does he keep
all of this or why does he keep this uh
this island? Why didn't Team Pixie
redact Lauren's name? I don't know.
Well, I think at some point I think at
some point Lauren de Laguna started
using Lauren Hayden publicly. I think
that could be part of it. I don't even
know what they mean by do I don't know
what that is referring to
necessarily or that like Lauren is
working for their officer right there.
That would be such a they would be
conflicted out. There's no way. He says
Tony Hinchcliffe is funny. Oh, that's
up. That's reallyed up. Oh, given what
happens later, he said Tony Hinchcliffe
was funny.
You'll understand why that's so
upsetting to me a little bit later. But
how have I Lauren?
They defined it differently in the
document.
Um Lauren Hayden or a friend doxing is
collecting somebody's personal
information and then making it public
for the purpose of harassing them.
Right. collecting personal information
about them and then directing harassment
via their way via that like publishing
it for the purpose of
harassment potential witness of
plaintiffs. Lauren is listed as an
individual likely to have discoverable
information on defendants initial
disclosures. If she's your friend, then
you don't need anything from me. She's
going to have she's going to have all of
the information herself. Why? Why do you
even I think actually initial disclosure
is disclos whatosing to me who might
have information but
like I yeah it's literally hey this
person might have
information I found the pass by my
defense first comments so it's got 20
seconds of rampant time. Okay give me a
second. Uh just with this I don't dude
what it's Yeah. It's literally letting
you know that we're we might ask this
person for information and you might
have they might have information so you
should know about them too. It's
literally like a good faith effort to
say these are people we might actually
use information from. So if you wanted
to ask them things here they
are. Anyway, hold on. Apparently this is
where he talks with the the lawyers. Uh
was it Professor Sunday or I'm sorry not
Professor Sunday. President Sunday's
channel.
Oh, wait a second.
Oh, wait. Hold on. What is there a link
to like the thing that I published?
Wait, I just realized something. I
despite the fact that everybody claims
otherwise because people think I'm
legitimately I guess people really do
think or some people I think. I don't
This is 3 weeks ago. So, I don't know
why this would necessarily have to do
with the manifesto. Haters or what think
I'm actually insanely arrogant. Um, I do
pass by. I pass everything I publish by
my lawyers first. Some people like, I
bet he's I bet he's stupid enough to
think that he's smarter than his lawyers
and does like, no, I'm not. I'm not. Why
would I even risk that? A pretty good
assessment of how smart I am. I would
never risk anything that stupid. Um, but
I just realize I wonder sometimes am I
referencing things that I put in a first
draft of a statement and not the actual
thing that got published. Now, um,
this one, we'll see.
Where is the um I made a public I made
like a when I did like my minifigesto.
Did I ever link that? I was gonna say
right here if he's talking about first
draft he's talking about the
minifigesto.
Okay. So the main things that make me
wonder,
wait, hold on. Is he talking about the
notes he sends to his lawyers? Because I
don't know if this is the one
necessarily, but hold on. So like for
instance, when that she knew that I was
in contact with, she's saying things
like um this I believe these like pretty
clearly mounts on, right? Um, I'm going
to decide reaction what to do with him
or myself and him based on how the
converation goes with the video. Unless
you want to talk basically my plan of
course something this conspiracy and
like I said before that Twitter archive
replies the tweets. Yes, that's very
weird. Yeah, I remember covering this
one. This is not quite it but that is
one of the statements but that one would
apply more to his minifesto. There's
another one where he talks about writing
notes to his lawyers. Right. It's the
quote. Yeah, it's the quote but I'm
saying that he has talked about how yeah
I don't just go live and talk about this
without my lawyer say so. Like I do pass
things by my lawyers. And he talked
about writing his notes, but it's fine.
We can
continue. She literally put her name on
the
GoFundMe. Like what? What the
She had her name on the give and go. I
think her name is still there, isn't it?
Giveo. Am I about to dox her again? Her
and her middle name. Did I just dox her?
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm
sorry. I'm
sorry. What?
I don't know what they mean by docs
here, but he absolutely directs
harassment at at Lauren and defames
Lauren, right? Multiple times claiming
that there's like some conspiracy here.
Like, dude, how does he argue? How could
he ever go do one of these like Trump
conspiracy arguments again? Maybe I'm
like totally I understand that it's a
bigger deal to talk about the election,
but the entire idea is you have like a
massive following of people who could do
something in the real world. Um, when
you when you make these arguments, when
you say something that is blatantly
false, that could hurt people, you're
doing something wrong, right? When you
are lying about Lauren de Laguna
repeatedly, that could have effects,
especially if she's trying to do
something in social media. You're going
to say that she's lying. Or I mean, just
she had, I think, issues with the
getting through the bar or something in
Florida, right? Like these these things
could have effects if you use their
names and if you publish these things
online, they could have effects. He did
also suggest filing an ethics complaint
against her. Yeah, he's like said Lauren
should be
disbarred. Like these things do have
effects, especially when you have a
large enough following and and you can
put weight into the world. Like what is
the argument against Hassan or bad
empanada or any of these people? How do
you how do you stand at all against bad
empanada and the CPS comments or like
him talking about Ethan as a parent?
What was illegal there? What comment was
illegal?
Where in the world does he get any idea
that he can stand up against bad empanad
and be like, I'm a better person than
you. I It's baffling.
Uh, by the way, the point of that is
that they're both bad people, okay? Not
that they're both good people, that
they're both bad people. Just to be
clear,
the defendant has spread lies about
Lauren and talked to get this part
because she's been support of a
plaintiff. What? Why is this even being
included? You're wasting there. Hold on.
I just wanted two things. There's two
things. Uh, so that's being included.
Oh, defendants initial disclosure. So,
it would be pixy pixie side. Okay.
So this would be I see. So this would be
that they're informing him of these
people who might have information.
Lauren would have been on that that's
saying Lauren would be could be involved
in this case. Just warning you and you
are continuously defaming this person,
right?
Yeah. Okay. There's two things that are
happening here. Why I think this is
gross as a as a non- lawyer and a
non-person or whatever. Right. So maybe
what I'm saying is there's two things
that are happening here. The first is a
party I have no sympathy for now, which
is Pixie. You're wasting her time and
you're destroying her life because as as
mired in conflict as I am right now, I
can still stream and make money and do
all this. My guess is Pixie is probably
hanging on by a
thread.
Uh-huh. Do see how disingenuous and
disgusting that this is actually this is
where I could actually get on like a
little bit of a rant about the how
disgusting this person is. Why does he
fain concern for Pixie's privacy or her
happiness or her well-being in any way?
Like, it's so disgusting and
disingenuous for him to do that, right?
It's the same thing he did with, "Oh, a
Abby looked at my wife's journal. She
looked at my wife's journal." It's like,
"You
sent you sent your wife's therapy
document that analyzed like all of the
things that went wrong in her life to
random anime PFPs on Discord. You
disgusting loser.
Why are you pretending to be concerned
about Molina's privacy right now? It's
so performative. It's so weird. It's
like so It's like so inhuman. It's so
lizardlike. Is actually cold blooded
based on the outcome of this particular
Okay, that's my guess just based on
recent tweets I've seen from her that
are all public. Right. So the fact that
you are wasting time from your
client, you're wasting time from your
client to throw the journal was shown to
the time before the docu. That's not the
pop-up book. The pop-up book's a
different thing. Robin random [__] about
again a nonparty to the case. Um Lauren
Hayden has not made any declarations to
the court. She's not a witness to any of
this. She's not like why are you wasting
your client's time on this? Number one.
And number two, the party that I by the
way when Pixie like posts that she's
depressed or something,
right? When uh when Pixie posts about
how she's depressed, if you go look at
that post in the replies, it's all DJers
who are shit-talking her, right? It's
they're all DGers
just very obviously do have sympathy for
is why are you wasting the court's time
with this like you're already elected to
file this in federal court. You wanted
to go to big boy federal court. So now
we're on a federal docket eating through
a federal judge's time that I imagine
probably have real cases to hear and
important [__] to hear even of these
same cardi claims. Like I said, if you
go I'll just I'll just say that again
through this whole thing where he
pretends that there's like no possible
case and there's no possible wrongdoing
for this entire thing. His only argument
he he signed a statement saying, "Yes, I
did send that video non-consensually to
some random person, but I did it 6
months before she could hold me liable
for it." Okay? Like anybody who's who's
arguing this on moral grounds, he
literally signed a statement saying he
did the thing that he's being sued for.
Yes, I did do that thing. Yes, I did. I
did do that thing. That's that is not a
matter of factual
contention. Destiny's lawyers will never
argue. No, no, no. He's never sent this.
They have admitted it. It is already
confessed. It is a mutually agreed upon
fact of this case. want to read the So
when he says there's nothing going on
here, right? Underlying case, the
Giuliani defense. Yes, I lied, but it's
my first amendment right to lie.
These are some crazy cases. Like the
defendants are genuinely unhinged and
crazy. But now you're wasting a judge's
time to go through your your your
MySpace posts. Like the is wrong. Why
would you do this?
So now we we're going to go and bicker
in front of a a federal judge who's what
supposed to play. It's just disgusting.
It's so gross to me. But
whatever. Again, um as we'll get to at
the end of this, obviously, as we went
through in the beginning, there's
literally the the the chat message from
Abby to her friend saying, "Yeah,
Destiny has sent me like videos of his
orbiters and acts like I don't know who
they are from his stream." Like that is
what the message
says. Like and and then he's like, "You
guys are crazy for acting like there's a
case here." Just because there's obvious
proof that I've admitted to that I sent
it and there's circumstantial evidence
that I sent it to other people after
Cardi came into effect. That doesn't
mean they should get to go through my
videos and see if I actually did it.
That's disgust. That's the most
disgusting thing I've ever heard of in
my life. Would your lawyers have been
able to file an objection to this motion
if they had file? Well, this isn't um I
don't think this is a motion. This is a
filing in support of their other motion.
Right. Motion for protective order
governing public commentary. Oh. Oh,
this is a gag order. This is a new
motion. Damn, we got a lot of motion in
this case. Jesus Christ.
Why is Destiny so mad? I thought this
was getting dismissed in summary
judgement. Hold on. Well,
uh,
this is from 2025, February 19th. I'm
not sure. The majority of this was
pushed by Lauren Hayden. If I could get
her disbar for this considering she
already failed
characterist Oh wait, hold on. That is
actually he does just name Lord. Oh, I
didn't realize he was like using her
full name and trying to say it. Like he
literally uses the full name. He I don't
even
know, dude. That's what they mean. Okay.
So, using her full name in his chat and
saying if I could get her disbarred.
Okay. Okay. So, he's conspir he's
literally defaming Laura in his chat.
File her case on February 18th,
right? Why are you using the fact that
you provided declarations meaning I
shouldn't be attacking Laura and then
providing a statement that I made before
any of those
declarations had ever even been made?
That could be a good point if the uh if
those declarations were made uh later.
Yeah, sure. Which I think that's
entirely possible they were. Let me see
when were
they. I'm scrolling. Court listener.
Give me a second.
Oh, initial
disclosures. Oh, were those made Oh,
those were made way
later. Yeah, sure.
Oh, wait. Hold on. It's not in these
initial
disclosures. So, maybe it is in his
initial disclosures. I don't know when
he did it. Jesus. I His initial
disclosures are not public from what I
can
tell. Also, the defendant has spread
lies about Lauren. going to talk about
how we like to get this part because
she's been supportive of
plaintiff not because of the fact that
she's you said I accused her earlier of
lying and all those things. Don't you
think that has more to do with I'm sure
there are people that are supportive of
I just all all he has to do here is
provide his evidence. He's 99% sure this
is all pushed by Lauren Hayden.
Evidence, please. Don't just
Can I get the Can I get the Yeah, I need
the meme. Hold on. We need this right
now. This is This is unironically just
doing the meme directly. Like literally
just tell me why you believe this. Can I
get any
anything? Say what you want about Kiwi
Farms. Okay. They they cite some things.
They they actually clip you doing [__]
They actually have evidence, right? This
is your evidence right now for like a
bunch of the you
say Lauren de Laguna set this all up.
She conspiring against me. I'm 99% sure
it was all
her. We're excited
that there crackpipe.
Listen, the Vance ain't hitting quite
right anymore. He's moved on to actual
meth. Okay, that's just the way it is.
plaintiff that I haven't bismerched. You
want to be supportive of a plaintiff,
then whatever. Knock yourself out. I
don't give a my issue with the people,
brother. Brother Wicked Supreme made one
off-handed remark about him him liking
Cosby and Louis CK and then liking
Destiny later in life. And you like
actually tried to make him seem like a
creepy. That's a guy you were actually
friends with cuz he made one offcolor
joke in my Discord.
Why are you acting like you aren't the
most malicious on planet Earth who are
doing bad things?
Okay, not most in like the in like the
online influencer sphere. Furthermore,
despite the protective order entered,
I'm sure there's some really
anti-semitic people somewhere that are
like very evil. Okay, this this is a gag
order. Hold on. Imagine the
audacity of trying to gag me after you
made a public post detailing everything
about the case. This this is it's so
disgusting. Pick it up.
Hello.
Oh. Oh, no. I'll tell them. Sorry.
Audacity calling. Got it.
I've been saving that one for the
perfect moment and that was it. Imagine
the audacity. Holy [__] I'm so [__]
I'm actually triggered. I want to do a
public gag after you published your
whole ass instinct cuz now you're not
happy that you didn't find anything. Now
you're not happy about the public
filings. Now you're not happy about the
how the court case is going. Like give
me a break, dude. That's so wild.
But furthermore, despite the protective
order entered by this court to protect
plaintiff Janeo's identity, defendant
publicly disclosed plaintiff's Jane Do's
legal name on his YouTube platform.
First of all, I think this was literally
the same day. Number one, I removed that
name. Number two, plaintiff literally
listed her name on the give sen go when
they first do you notice how like okay
when they published it. So the plaintiff
has already made their name public. They
clearly didn't mean to do that. I I
think they it seems pretty clear they
didn't mean to do that. All of the
damages associated with this case even
have nothing to do with plaintiff's
name. It has everything to do with her
identity which is Pixie. And she's using
her online name and everything again.
Uh I can't make the identity argument
again.
Like all I feel like this entire court
case is just like trying to like lay
traps and then see if I fall into the
traps. And it's
like like traps like when he said uh I
have absolutely never under under
penalty of Persia, I've absolutely never
sent that video to anybody else. And
then somebody comes forward with like
clearly they're like well Destiny
deleted the video link actually. But um
I do have vlogs to these other people
where I describe these videos that
nobody knew about two like a year and a
half before they ever came out.
Jesus that
trap you not file this motion at the
start of the case. True. There's a lot
of stuff they like the TRO for instance
that they should
have. Um I don't know why this is
getting filed later. I'm guessing her
lawyers are yeah like pinned for time or
something. I don't know what the [__] is
going on with them.
But lots of the content or lots of the
conduct isn't until like a couple weeks
ago, right? Him going after the lawyers
isn't until a couple weeks ago. Him
going after Abby isn't until a couple
weeks ago. After plaintiff brought this
to the attention of the court in her
reply to the opposition or motion
preliminary junction, the defendant
removed the reference plane. However,
defendant did not delete another
reference he made to her name at minute
11:34. Why then? Why not ask me? Meet
and confer. If you know there are
additional mentions, I deleted the one
they asked. If there were additional
mentions, then just request it. It'll
get deleted. What? Do you think I want
to mention? No. This is a spite. Why
would you Again, why would you hold on
to this
for Dude, I don't I don't know why. Why
is he assuming they held on to it? Why
wouldn't it just be, oh, somebody like
went and searched it again and let them
know later or something? Why is it all
like a malicious plan to to malign him
to him over 4 months? You actually gave
a about your identity. Why are you
holding on to this? Moreover, in the
chat thread that accompanies this video,
after 758, his followers then repeatedly
refer to Pliff's name. Why are you
listing this in a public filing if you
give a about your
name? Um, I'm guessing, well, I'm I'm
guessing the point is that you're not
taking any actual initiative in doing
this, in like trying to protect this.
And it's also good evidence that you are
not the only person that when you do
this, when you do this performative
thing on screen, you're actually
training a whole bunch of other people
to do it as well, right? And that's a
part of their argument is you have a
massive audience and you you get that
audience to go after people to to
continue to spread these messages you're
doing. So, so like I could theoretically
I guess I won't show it on stream
although I don't know why not because
it's all in a public
filing. I think he's assuming or they
might be assuming you'll take it down or
do something about it, but hard to
say. Why would you include this? So now
that you're just Why would you do this?
What the?
Oh my god.
Defendant did not remove those comments
containing plaintiff's name and so they
are still public. These actions are
meant to defeat the protections afforded
to plaintiff of filing as a Jane Doe.
You defeated those protections when you
literally launched a Substack
identifying yourself in the videos and
then launched a G send that was attached
to your real life name that was all
public facing. No, I I don't believe you
forfeit your right to privacy because of
a mistake. And I'd say probably even
trying to like actually push people to
look at those things is probably another
way of getting around it, right? He's
going to go live on stream. He's going
to say, "But you publish it this way,
but you you put your real name over
here. You put your real name over there.
You put your real name over here and
over
there. Come on. Give me a
break. This video has been viewed over
130,000 times. And the same um it was
after that message to him about our
emotional distress. And I would imagine
if he wanted to challenge that, right?
He probably should have challenged that
when they applied for those things and
opposed those back then. Thought dude is
nonentual. I don't think I don't think
anything's changed since then. Then
mocks and ridicules her. He then tells
his father's motive solely for the
purpose of extorting him.
Well, technically there was another
person that claimed that in response to
Pixie's measures to them, but yeah. Now,
don't hate the
messenger. Cool. Destiny and President
Sunday best buddies. Destiny and
President Sunday best friends forever.
Let's go.
I thought I thought when Sunday called
Destiny fat and disgusting with like a
really gross patchy beard that when
Sunday repeatedly pointed out how how
patchy Destiny's beard was. I thought he
got put on the Omega blacklist, but
apparently they're close enough now that
Destiny's just like, "What's up, Sunday?
We best
buds." Numerous individuals initially
contacted Plaintiff with information
pertinent to this action, but have
refused to provide testimony due to fear
of retaliation and or
dox what I can I make up. Where's my
lawyer? Can I just Am I allowed to just
say this? I've had 50 different people
tell me that plaintiff is actually
engaged in all sorts of, but they don't
want if none of this happened. I hope he
realizes that the identities wouldn't be
kept from his lawyers like in any case.
I don't believe they could, I believe,
be kept from him. The the lawyers could
be ordered not to give the identities to
him, but those identities would be on
the record. And if any of those people
were lying, they would be open to
subpoena. they would be open to being uh
to having their log subpoenaed or
whatever. If any of those people were
lying or making things up about them,
they would be open up to the same opened
up to the same penalties by
participating in the case that anybody
else would. They can't participate
without their names. The penalties for
them lying would be the same as
penalties for anybody else. Why is he
pretending that there wouldn't be a
penalty? There would be no consequence
to just making something
up. What does he think they just added a
bunch of things into the law that you
could just make allegations and nobody
could possibly punish you for them and
you just withdraw them? No. No judge
could go, "Wait, wait, hold on. Did you
have a reason to make that allegation?"
I I don't understand. There's like such
an obvious loop. There'd be such an
obvious loophole that would the whole
justice system. Why does he think that
that's the way it works? Want to say it.
They don't actually want to come. Well,
sorry. That's That question answers
itself. He doesn't think it's the way
that it works. He just knows that he can
say whatever he he wants to this gaggle
of clapping seals, these clapping seals,
and they will
go that totally made it up about you.
until they make it
to tell me the joke about his [__]
mom
again. Forward and identify themselves.
They don't actually want to put that in
writing anywhere. This is
hearsay. And in some cases, this is
double hearsay. Like why? Like they're
not even
present. See exhibit A. Besides the
three witnesses who have provided
declarations under seal, by the way,
none of those three witnesses, well,
technically one of them is actually
relevant to the case, but no evidence
has been provided for anything they've
said.
Oh. Uhoh.
Oh, I guess did he did he actually not
read this stuff before he went live? He
just decided to go live and
the original. God, it's going to be such
a good summer. I can feel it. Do you
guys feel the energy in the air that
it's going to be a good summer? We're
going to have a great time. It's just
going to be I think it's going to be
awesome. I don't know how this case is
going to go. I can just feel like I just
feel like there's some energy in the air
that I I just know it's going to be a
good summer. You guys ever feel that? I
can feel it's like uh it's hot in my
place. I don't have the air conditioning
on. It's like humid. It's hot. Uh I have
the the window open. Um I can hear the
crickets outside. I can just feel it's
just the energy of the it's it's
infecting me. I'm just I'm I don't know,
man. It's going to be good. It's going
to be great. Multitude of individuals
who initially contacted Plaintiff. There
are now only
three with whom plaintiff still has
contact because the majority deleted
their accounts after Destiny posted his
video on YouTube titled Destiny
addresses his lawsuit on February. Wait,
so you're telling me that you made a
Substack in
January. You had people contact you.
Yeah. You didn't take down any names.
You didn't take down any statements.
probably they took down statements and
whatever names those people were willing
to give. Lots of those people opened up.
I I'm sure I could find some of these
statements. I kept logs of a bunch of
these things, but like these people
said, "Hey, please never leak this." I'm
terrified of what this guy would
do. I'm like terrified of what this guy
would
do. That's that's just what they do,
man. That's that's how it was. They
people message me. I had people message
me from like multiple accounts where
they would be like, "Hey, here's like a
little bit here. Hey, here's a little
bit here. I'm really worried about
this." And then they go away for a
while. They deactivate their account or
something. They message me on a
different account. Even people I knew. I
had people I knew. I knew their
identity. I knew them. I'd had
conversations with them who messaged me
from fake accounts to be like, "Hey, I
don't really want to talk about this,
but like I don't want this tied to my
identity, but like here's what I got
told. Here's like what I was sent."
Yeah, that that absolutely happened. I
just You didn't sign any affidavit. You
didn't verify anything they said. Then
you filed a court case and you went back
to look for them and their accounts were
gone. Are you crazy? This is insane. Do
you even know if these people were
real? Yes.
Yep. Or were they? And he docks those
people. Well, uh I mean he definitely
points people at Kiwi Farms, too. some
docs that are on Kiwi Farms of people
who came forward as witnesses. Or is it
literally did Kiwi Farms literally troll
this into filing a court case? Are you
[__] ser? Oh, that's actually I don't
know if you can do that.
No, no, you must be able to get people
to sign affidavit. But yeah, you'd have
to file a court case and you'd have to
retain legal
counsel. But yeah, I think um they had
what do you call it? They had like the
proof that it was sent. They had proof
that there was a huge pattern. Once you
have proof that it was sent once and you
have a huge pattern of people getting
all kinds of videos of all b a whole
bunch of different women. By the way, if
you've ever sent a video to Destiny or
received a video from Destiny, you're
probably getting non-conensually sent to
you, right? Not sent to you
non-consensually.
Non-consensually sent to you like like
it was incredibly pervasive. Okay. So,
just, you know, if you happen to be
watching this for some reason on
YouTube, yeah, you're probably in the
group of people who got sent stuff that
there was not consent for that to be
sent to you. Serious right
now. So, anyway, massive pattern and the
proof of it being sent in the Rose
thing. I think that's enough to file the
case and and continue to talk to people.
Yeah,
absolutely. Yeah, I don't think that's
crazy at
all. Wait, you're on YouTube? I am not.
But I assume when I do Destiny stuff,
Riyle tends to post that stuff. So I
just assume with this it'll get posted.
The god three individuals with whom
plaintiff still has contact have told
that they're afraid of speaking out or
testifying
because I see I see Stacia as her online
name and I see Hannah posting every
single day in other people's Discord
chats about all of this. They're clearly
not. Oh, my ears are burning. What
Discord? What Discord? Could he just say
discord.gg/jlk? Could he help a brother
out? Help a brother
out. Um I don't know, he's like probably
trying to remember
that. Like he's he's acting like you
guys uh didn't know each other, right?
It's it's very strange. It's very
strange. And here here's my one skitso
theory of the day. Okay, I'll throw this
out there. The one skitso theory. I
don't want to be a total [__] about
it, but like realistically, he probably
saw some Twitter post or some message
you sent saying it's kind of annoying
that they can't get my name right and
did that. I'm telling you, that's like
the level of petty he is. He probably
saw some like some Discord post or some
Twitter post where you were like, it's
weird that they can't get my name right
and he was like Stoia, whoever that is.
He's a
petty. Yep. is a petty contact have told
her after that they are afraid of
speaking out or testifying against cynic
because I see I see Stacia is her online
name Stacia and I see Hannah posting
every single day in other people's
discord chats about all of this they're
clearly not afraid they're clearly not
intimidated they talk all the time about
this constantly they can't help
themselves they can't help themselves
but constantly talk about all of this
what are you talking about
uh that overt dummy you just messaged
me. That's probably from the case, just
so you know. That's probably just from
the case. Um, okay. What am I trying to
think of? I just had something to say.
God damn it. I got sent to Discord about
this constantly. They can't help
themselves. They can't help themselves,
but constantly talk about all of this. I
would imagine people who like had an
intimate relationship with you that they
thought you like cared about them or had
like you know positive feelings concern
were concerned for their well-being or
their futures or anything and then
realized that you were
sending that you shot with them to other
people without their consent. They
probably had a pretty harsh like meeting
with reality. It was probably pretty up
and they probably don't like
you. They just probably don't like you,
bro. I don't know what to tell you.
What? What am I What else am I supposed
to say? Obviously, they think you
suck. Yeah, they might talk about it. I
don't know why that's
weird. And I don't know who this is with
whom plaintiffs still contact have told
her they are afraid of speaking out or
testifying against. Okay, so this would
be probably be the people who haven't
testified, right? I would imagine. What
are you talking
about? Jesus.
Does he realize that it's even worse
that he is doing that doing this bad to
people and cares so little about them
that he can't remember their names?
Doesn't make him look better. Uh yeah.
No, no doubt that he like had like a
relationship with this person where he
talked to them like fairly often all the
time um with like these people, right?
And then he's pretending he doesn't even
know them, pretending that they like
didn't matter. It's like yeah, that
would actually be worse. That would be
worse, Destiny. That you had no concern
for these people at all. That you can't
even remember their names. makes you
look like a again like a sort of like
inhumane lizard
person. Disgusting. Cold blooded.
Federal rule of civil 2016 specifically
authorized the court for good cause
issue an order to protect a party or
person from annoyance. Uh I'm going to
skip through this stuff because it's
just this is not
really Are you exhibit A before
finishing? Why I'm trying
to what are are you
spoiling? Hold on. I'm getting water. I
Jane Do declares follows. I'm over the
Who is
this? I won't say the name, but I'm
curious. Did we actually get any copies
of any of these or am I going into my
hearing tomorrow with absolutely no idea
who any of these people are? Let's
see. Don't have it there. What about
this is Hold on. Is there not only one
Jane Doe? I thought there was um like
when they say Jane Doe with no other
clarification, I believe that's Jane
Doe. There's only one Jane Doe with
regards to this case. Nope. That's
redacted. That's the Jane Doe. Can you
just start reading for two seconds?
Redacted. Redacted for two seconds.
Great. That's nice. Cool. So, I get to
go into this here. I have no idea who
any of these. Okay, cool. Base. Let's
see what they say.
Dude, thank God for this case. He's
going to sense so much on butt plugs
because he is so eternally ass pained
every time he looks at this case. It's
like he's plugged up right now. He
didn't even put it in. He's just
infinitely ass pained. Just read the
document,
idiot. Put the dock in the bag in the
Put the fries in the bag, Lobo. Put the
the legal dock in the bag. Just read it.
We'll all be fine. You'll be okay. It'll
soothe you. Just go. No. Maybe I can
figure it out.
Little publicly. I misspoke. Okay,
that's not exhibit A. You can't hang
around for Dan. You can't hang around
with Dan for as long as I did and not
misspeak occasionally. Oh, exhibit A's
down here. Oh, too late. We're reading
this anyway now.
Personal matters here. I called it. I'm
testifying in declaration in support of
Lind's motion protective order to govern
you. I can contest the fact that um
defendant Steven Bonell's actions
hearing the willingness of witnesses to
come forward and testify in this action
when I Oh, this is just Pixie.
Yeah, Jane. Why does she not say she am
I not allowed to use the online name
anymore? No, you are my first online
name is included. of 2025 that I would
be taking legal action against the
defendant. Numerous individuals
contacted me with information they
believed was current to the case. The
majority of these individuals informed
me that the defendant is now we have to
we have to all pretend every DJer. Okay,
Destiny, that's Jane Doe. Read exhibit
A. Okay. Well, the zip zip guy is saying
like obviously this is who it is. Okay.
All right. Maybe that guy's not as but
like do we all just pretend he didn't
just go on a whole rant about how it's
soed up that they keep redacting these
names I have no idea who they are
individuals without consider that has
nothing to do with the case that's not
pertinent that's not relevant to this
case why are you even including this one
of these individuals whose screen name
was
xxx told me the defendant sent the video
depicting me to their
sister is this double here say
What? This individual and their sister
as well as other individuals who
initially hunted me completely deleted
their accounts. Dude, are you actually
serious?
Um, I mean, this isn't really like
strong evidence, but it is evidence. It
is like why they initially filed with
the stuff that they did, right? This is
a this is this was a part of the initial
complaint.
Uh, Crazy Monk 27. No, you are wrong.
For those pieces of evidence to be
considered by the jury, they would have
to be given as affidavit. You can't just
do hearsay. They would have to give
affidavit statements under penalty of
perjury. Otherwise, they're not even
being included on the record. They won't
be presented to a jury. If this sister
thing never pans out and is never
anything, it will not be presented to a
jury at all.
Destiny has like invented this fiction
in completely cognitively people's heads
and unfortunately they they continue to
come here and like
spew this will not be presented to a
jury. It will not be considered
evidence. It's in here because I don't
know why Pixie included it to be honest.
It's in her statement. I don't know why
but it's there. This can't be real,
right? This has to Yes. Sorry. The
affidavit would be under would be at
risk of perjury. But I'm saying that the
thing where Pix, somebody messaged Pixie
on Discord and said, "Hey, my sister got
this video." That won't be presented to
a jury unless that is uh backed up by an
affidavit or backed up by some kind of
Discord logs, evidence, that kind of
thing,
right? Those won't be presented to the
jury. Be a
joke. This individual and their sisters,
as well as other individuals who had
initially contacted him, completely
deleted their accounts after Destiny
posted his video on YouTube entitled
Destiny Addresses Lawsuit on February
20th,
2025. I I I legitimately You know what?
Also
props props to you know
what the farmers are brave people then
why present it if it will never be I
don't know why they're presenting it
here I think they included it because
they thought basically they were going
to get a statement from this person
right so they included in the initial
complaint as one of the things that they
were include like they said this is why
we believe it falls under Cardi yeah
it's in support of the motion oh no no
hold on oh sure this is now this is now
evidence that these things happened
saying this motion is about hey people
are scared this is now evidence of them
being scared and it is evidence of that
true but it was included in the initial
complaint it is evidence of this
actually yeah I don't know why you're
right latigious gamer it is saying that
like these people came forward offered
evidence and then deleted their account
it's weak evidence right it's not I
wouldn't say that you would grant the
motion based on this but it is a part of
the motion it is a piece of evidence in
good job support of the motion it was an
epic troll epic troll
In this video, the defendant further
violates my privacy publishing. There's
almost 1 million followers. Out of
context, private messages. Oh, I'm
sorry. Do we need more context with the
private
messages? Crazy monk 27. You have
absolutely no idea what you're talking
about. You are clearly cognitively. You
probably still hang out in Destiny all
the time. I don't know why you're in
here concern trolling. Have a good one.
Out of context. I'm sorry. Is Hassan
suing me now?
The three women that provided
declarations under seal and sort of
plain dismotion for learning. Sorry, I'm
like I'm really just like done with the
people who come in. They're like, "Well,
I you know, it seems to me that like
everybody kind of up here." No, you just
don't pay any attention. You're totally
mentally. Just walk away. Don't watch.
You don't have to watch. You could just
walk away and save your dignity. Don't
come here and concern troll. Loser
junction expressed fear of being
publicly targeted or doxed by defendant
and or his followers and indicated
they're unwilling to participate in dis
I just does this loser who comes in and
types the random concern trolling the
chat does he not understand that Destiny
literally if you if you actually morally
care about sending to other people
without their consent that Destiny's
already admitted he signed he he swore
in a statement okay he signed an
affidavit saying I sent that video it
was just 6 months before Cardi but I
totally did send it I totally did it
without consent. Yep. Yep. Discovery or
testify unless her identities remain
confidential. Well, but two of these
people, the Hannah person, um, for this
reason, the witness declarations are
filed under seal. Well, Hannah's wasn't.
And then you put the screen names of
Bro, this is so Oh my god, dude. Get me
out of here. Get me the out of They talk
about this daily. I have so many um I
have so many screenshots, too. That's
going to be wild. So, here are the
people, by the way, who are afraid of um
talking about the about testifying
because their legal names could be
included in the case and they don't want
to testify with their legal names
protected. Again, he's he's doing the
the conflation of legal name and
pseudonym that he refuses to admit is
real, but no, everybody knows is real.
But let me tell you, judge, your honor,
look at all the testimony that they're
okay leaving in this other dude's
Discord server. H
Besides uh Oh, wait, wait, wait. Oh,
says there are four additional witnesses
I have contact with. But they have told
me that they are afraid of speaking out
or testifying against the defendant
because of his likely retaliation and
harassment. Attached here to as exhibit
A is a true and correct copy of one of
the witnesses named XXX who has
communicated to me her fear of
defendant. Okay. Exhibit A.
You dox fans randomly. No.
Wait, why is he avoiding saying your
name now? Uh, I think it's because Well,
it's totally disingenuous, but I think
it's cuz they're implying that um his
threats to me were bad. Wait, hold on. X
who has communicated to me her fear of
defendant. Okay, exhibit A.
It's just that I don't have money for a
lawyer or anything. Once he knows my
name or something, I'm afraid he's going
to harass me or get others do something.
What What would they even need a lawyer
for if they're just a witness or
declaration?
They don't want you to get their name.
That's what they just said. As you
constantly pointed out that even if
things were filed under seal, you should
still get their name. Yeah, they're very
worried that with that name he will do
something.
Also,
this is on January 22nd before I even
released that YouTube video as well as
initially haunting me completely deleted
their accounts ever posted this YouTube
video on February 20th. They literally
told That's one of the pe That's one of
the people who didn't delete, right?
January
22nd. What? I That was one of the people
she was still in contact with. What even
is this screenshot? What is this? I I
don't know. I can't know who these
people are. I'm not random. Why do they
keep filing secret evidence? Ignore
everything. I'm so Okay, this is the
difference between being Why do they
keep filing secret evidence? Street
smart and being books smart. Okay, cuz I
read all this boring stupid legal, okay?
But then when you look at how Trump's
lawyers argue, the solicitor general
argues in front of the Supreme Court,
okay? Or you see these arguments, none
of that actually matters. Okay? All of
that was And why are you pretending you
belong in this field or with these names
or these people in any way? These people
that you're naming right now are all far
more educated than you. You've read a
couple Wikipedia articles. You've used
some not not unlike me, by the way. I
probably have less legal experience than
Destiny. Okay? I don't know if I could
argue. Listen, I'm like 1,000th of a
lawyer. Destiny is like 3 1000 of a
lawyer. Okay? Like we're we're legally I
admit that. I don't know why he's like
these these people argue before the
Supreme Court. I was like, "Brother, you
are you are an uneducated. Stop
pretending you know
anything." Like, and by the way, unless
Pixie's lawyers are severely reprimanded
and sanctioned for their conduct in that
magistrate hearing tomorrow, unless I'm
not saying that the judge goes, "Hey,
you should have done this. Hey, that's
bad." If they aren't like hit with
actual serious
sanctions, he you you can't take him
seriously anymore, right? you you you
literally can't take him seriously at
all. I don't know if he thinks like
later when he's like, "Well, I'm not
sure that they will be sanctioned after
he's gone on like a multi-hour rant
about how these people are the most
disgusting people he's ever met and they
will be saying they're they're just
terrible people. They they need to be
sanctioned. They can't they shouldn't
even be doing this. They're so
unqualified to practice law." If if it
goes through with nothing, he looks like
a complete fool. Now, I think there's
it's possible the judge would go, "Hey,
you should have sent them the names or
something." I think that's the most
likely outcome. He's still the same
overconfident 15-year-old libertarian
who reads Atlas Shrugged and understood
economics better than anyone. Yeah,
that's basically that's some that
basically summarizes his entire career,
right? But he Hey, I'll give him this.
He's incredibly good at optics. He like
he makes it look like he knows very well
what he's talking about, right? He's
basically just extremely skilled at
making other people look bad. That's
like what he does most of the time. All
of it was This is street law. This is
the real [__] I have no idea what this
message is. I don't know who it's sent.
I don't even know who it's about. It
doesn't even mention my name. I I don't
worry about the timer. I'll just put the
timer away.
We don't need a timer. We're just
watching this.
Uh yeah, F. Listen, if he's 100% right,
then I have to come on my stream. I'm
not going to quit streaming if he's 100%
correct. I'm not. I'm going to have to
come on and just be like, "Wow, Pixie's
lawyers just got disbarred. I look like
a
idiot." But I
listen, I just assume he'd be making
some slightly better arguments if that
were the case,
right? I just I think there'd be
slightly better arguments. He wouldn't
look so It wouldn't be so embarrassing
to listen to.
Dude, the hand flailing in
this What are this? Totally random. It's
totally rand. You guys can't see me
flame flailing my hands around, but it's
totally random, guys. It's totally
random.
Apparently, they use the word
gaslighting. Uh, can they do that
legally? Are they allowed to use
gaslighting as a term?
Destiny has tried to repeatedly dox one
of these witnesses whose screen name is
X after he publicly expressed his
support for me. This potential witness
will not testify to pertinent
information regarding the case unless
his information can be protected. Blank
is expected to be providing any further
information after defendant publicly
called for his death on the defendant's
YouTube channel. Why would you Okay, so
it's either So it's it's one of two
people.
Yeah, I think so. It's pretty obvious
that that's like me or maybe one of
four. Me, Queen, Laugh, Mr. Girl, right?
It's pretty obvious. Now, let's keep
that in mind. Okay, let's keep that in
mind for a little bit later. Attached to
his exhibit B is a true and correct copy
of his communication to me expressing
his fear defendant. Let's see if we can
figure out who this one is.
[Laughter]
Oh. Ah, good
times. How do you do anything but laugh?
How do you do anything but laugh
there? It's funny. Okay, this could be
the best part of the stream. He does get
up and walk away. Um, but I will
say, hold on. Do not redact her own
nickname, and we all know
it's Yeah. Uh, the name is attached to
the lawsuit, and I literally don't care
about my pseudonym being attached at
all. I've never cared. I literally, if I
could give a statement, he's he is
right. They won't take affidavit from
people under pseudonyms, right? So, I
said, which I came on stream and said,
by the way, that if they can protect my
legal name, then I will give a
statement. And if they can't protect my
legal name, I will not give a statement.
That's how it is. Okay? This out here
saying these morons who have nothing to
live for, okay? Extremely low IQ,
worship this guy like he's a god, and
have basically nothing to live for. I
don't want my legal name out there at
all.
Props to giving the statement. Uh I have
not given the state. I don't know if
this order is going through. If they get
this gag order and whatever the gag
order and
um and they can file those things under
seal, yeah, I'll give them the
statement. But I'm not I'm not doing it.
But I'm I already said, yeah, I'm not
doing that with him like telling people
they should kill me.
That sorry, we should get through to
whenever he comes back.
gone for a minute.
Sorry, I didn't mean to skip through too
much.
There we go. Be
back. You know, uh they listen if they
came up and like actually wanted to
fight or something maybe. Although there
like I don't I might be okay cuz most of
the fitness guys are in my community
now, but like I I don't know. I don't
listen. There's going to be some
inshaped DJs. There's going to be like
some bro look at Gojo. If Gojo If Gojo
came for me, that would be up. I would I
would not stand a
chance. Okay, there's going to be some
like lifting incels who would be in
insane shape.
Okay, I'm not taking the
risk. Like, it's only funny because I'm
rich. Like, dude, if I if I was in this
financial or the financial position I
was in like even like 5 years ago, this
would be legitimately like a horrific
experience. This is just like this is
insane. Oh, wait. I thought it was
already the most disgusting horrific
experience you've ever been
through. Was it Is it not the most
disgusting horrific thing that's ever
happened to you? Or did that change?
Also, like this is funny.
I I I I wish I knew more of like the
sanctional arguments like her attorneys
I think should be like severely
reprimanded because let's assume that
this was an ordinary Cardier case. Let's
assume this was a case where this
federal law is usually invoked. I've
said this before. I think we've gone
through one or two of these on stream.
Somebody can link me a card as they
want. The defendants are actually crazy.
These men are insane. They're shooting
these videos um sometimes on alternate
accounts to plaintiffs friends, family
members, co-workers. They're crazy. A
lot of these defendants are right crazy.
If you want to litigate a case like
this, involves relatively sensitive
information. If you're not qualified to
do the case, then pass it over to
someone who is. There must be some rule
against like if I let's say I go to the
University of Law School of Nebraska and
I pass the bar or whatever and then some
guy like says, "Can you be my defendant
for like a quadruple homicide case?" And
I don't even know anything about I was
like, "Yeah, let's do like I'm pretty
sure you can. I think that's like a I
don't think you can do that. You must
not be able to." I'm saying I I think
the only qualification they have for
practicing law is that you pass the bar,
right? Like if somebody couldn't afford
an attorney, isn't that the whole point
of like I'm I'm pretty sure I I don't
get it. I I just don't get
it. What he just said applies to him. uh
friends, family, and co-workers. Oh, I
wasn't I'll be honest. I was not
necessarily listening for this past I
was getting another time stamp. Hold on.
Let me go back. Experience. My bad.
I I tapped out there for a second. I got
I wish I knew more of like the
sanctional arguments. Like her
attorneys, I think, should be like
severely reprimanded because let's
assume that this was an ordinary Cardi
case. Let's assume this was a case this
federal law is usually invoked. Oh,
those guys are crazy. I think we've gone
through one or two of these strings. Let
me get one. The defendants are actually
crazy. These men are insane. They're
shooting these videos on alternate
accounts to plaintiffs friends, family
members, co-workers. They're Oh, see,
no, Riy, you said it was the same,
right? He was shooting the video of his
friends and family and co-workers. Okay,
that's what he he was shooting the video
of his friends, families, and co-workers
to other people, not to those
people. Key key distinction. You were
very close, but not quite crazy. A lot
of these defendants are right. If you
want to litigate a case like uh true
actually Carrick true he was sending
yeah there was a lot of uh he was also
sending it to them. Yeah, true. That is
involves relatively sensitive
information. If you're not qualified to
do the case, then pass it over to
someone who is there must be some rule
against like if I let's say I go to the
University of Law School of Nebraska and
I the performative concern again, right?
The performative concern like he gives a
about other people. Oh my god, there's
just if this if this if I were actually
a monster that did the things they
accused me of, which they've accused him
of going live on his stream and publicly
maligning the people involved in the
case to his massive audience and opening
them up to
harassment. He's he's actively in the
process of doing that. While he's
saying, "If I was the monster they
painted me as, if I was really what they
accused me of being, you've done every
behavior they actually pointed out in
this stream so far in the last 30
minutes, 60 minutes. car or whatever and
then some guy like says, "Can you be my
defendant for like a quadruple homicide
case?" And I don't even know anything
about like, "Yeah, let's do like I'm
pretty sure you can. I think that's like
a I don't think you can do that. You
must not be able to." I'm saying, "I
think I'm just relying on
common." He's relying on common sense.
Does Destiny understand that you're
allowed to represent yourself in court?
allowed to choose the representation you
want? What What common sense is he
referring to?
How would there be a law against
somebody who is literally past the bar
representing someone else when a person
can actually self-represent? It sounds
like it. Maybe you can. Like this is
like imagine if I was the bar like if I
was the unhinged person.
Oh, it's so sad. I see names sometimes.
MVT77 was like in here and he was cool
and he's just I said this though. I told
you guys this that there would be people
who literally like can't actually
survive without hearing Destiny's voice
and it would be a very painful journey
to go from like to to go to not hearing
it and a lot of them weren't going to
make it. I just very sad. I just get
very sad that these people say that I
was. You've leaked so many identities to
me. You've leaked so many of these
identities and you're not even using the
correct blackout
again tools. You're not even using the
right. It looks like you did. They color
over this with a marker and then MVT was
a mod here. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't know. Is he pretending that um
it wouldn't be obvious from this that
it's me?
I don't even know if they actually just
I don't understand if he's pretending
that it wouldn't be obvious from this
and the the this has to be set up,
right? The only reason why they're doing
this is Yeah. I think the whole case is
just trying to get me to cuz they know
they have no case. So, it's just wasting
my time, wasting my money, destroying my
reputation, trying to destroy my life.
It's just that's the goal. It's It is
act It is literally I as much as I hate
to say it, it is the red pill nightmare
scenario of like the actual hardest case
scenario of that. Why the hardest? He's
going to be raped. Are you guys Are you
guys actually ready for Destiny to go on
the Whatever podcast and it's going to
be him and him and Andrew. Okay. Him and
Andrew Wilson arguing against some
feminists and being like, "Oh, you think
you think she wasn't just a gold digger?
You think she's not just a gold digger?"
Well, let me tell you something.
Why did they black out her avatar but
not redacted? I don't want to say his
name.
Do you mind if if I say I sat down with
your attorneys? Yeah, sure. What day?
What for? Exactly. I just wanted to say
it today. Bretter just filed a motion in
opposition and I'm going to say this is
precisely why I refused to give an
affidate because Dr. himself is saying
calling for my death is too much. Wait,
are is are is are they plotting and
scheming behind the scenes on how to
h and she's trying to gag me?
What? Where's the plotting and scheming
against me while she's literally working
behind the scenes with this guy to try
to optimize for his coverage?
Pixie didn't message me. I messaged
Pixie and said, "Hey, do you mind if I
say sit down with your attorneys cuz I'm
going to do the I
I Dude, I don't even What is happening?
I I literally was like, "Hey, um I don't
know if you like want if you don't want
me to do this. If you don't want me to
mention, I won't." But like I do you
mind if I say this cuz I just want to
say like this is actually why I I
wouldn't do it. It's like this guy's
calling for my death. Obviously is up.
You understand? I I'm not going to I'm
not going to risk my identity getting
put on paper when he's calling for my
death. That's like too much. Sorry. I
feel like Ethan Klein, dude. This is Oh,
he's having a schizophrenic meltdown.
biggest um like paranoia conspiracy,
right? Although I already had this
basically confirmed on the day that the
gift send me go was made and I saw
Lauren's name on I was like, "Ah, that
makes sense, right?"
Uhhuh. Jesus Christ.
I Yeah, he is just with absolutely
um sorry this is a joke I got before
this as well.
It's very interesting to see him so
confused right now because he can't
identify what is happening here. It's a
mysterious phenomenon that he has never
before considered. I showed up and I
said I I did something he he would never
have thought to do. I asked for
consent. I know. I know. Crazy crazy
move. Okay. Absolutely wild. I was like,
"Hey, do you mind if I do this? Hey, can
I can I can I do you mind if I do this
thing?" Oh, yeah. Okay. Oh, nice. Nice.
He's like, "Oh, that's what is is that
what explicit consent looks like?" Oh.
Oh, is saying my cell plus destiny call.
He's he's literally like one of the
androids from um from Westworld. Okay.
He sees a screenshot of somebody asking
for explicit consent and he's like,
"Doesn't look like anything to me. It's
a conspiracy." Why? I have no idea
what's going on. That's too much. But
I've already if I've already done this,
then why do you even care?
What? Like, your honor, um, it's just
very obvious. Uh, you failed dox me. I'm
not going to dox my legal name in this
case,
okay? And open myself up to actually
getting harassed in real life. No thank
you. No thank you. No thank you. You've
you've literally tried to You tried to
dox me and then call for my death. I do
not want to actually dox myself in these
public documents and make that a reality
for
you with my legal
name. I don't think this is confusing to
anybody with, you know, two brain cells
to rub together for a spark. It's
apparently It's not I'm sure it's not
confusing to him. He's trying to present
it as confusing so that when he goes
when he goes, I can't think of any
reason this would happen. I Why would
this actually be a problem for you? It's
actually for all of the again clapping
seals over here. He can convince them
that there's nothing they could possibly
think of, right? Because they'll never
ever consider something that Destiny
hasn't told them they should consider.
It's it's like actually just a blind
spot. He's creating blind spots for
them. Yes. My name is Steven Bunell and
I'm from Miami, Florida. What brings you
to court today? Your honor, I Steven
Bunell, who lives in Miami, Florida,
does not wish to give any more
commentary on this because I don't want
people to know my name or my address.
Thank you, sir. You're
dismissed.
Like, stalker show this on stream today.
What did he
say? Oh, this is the best part. This is
the best
part. What did he say? I think he
thought Did he think I was going to like
moralize about this or say it wasn't a
mistake or
I actually don't know what he thought.
This just shows This just shows Jtock is
gonna
lie. Whoa, it's Kyle. This just shows
Jtock is gonna lie because I asked Pixie
if she minded if I said that uh I talked
to her attorneys, asked for consent to
mention that on stream, and then went on
my stream and said, "Hey, uh tying my
legal name to this case when Desi's
calling for my death would be concerning
to me."
It's literally
It's It's I don't Okay, continuing.
Sorry. We got to go to the best part of
the stream. One second. Are they taking
turns getting the 10-page motion?
This is them admitting to just go lying,
right?
[Music]
Um, they're like trying to get
performatively outraged for him ahead of
time. This isn't proof of him lying,
right?
Oh, why are you assuming this first
statement is a lie? Do you mind if I say
I sat down with your attorneys? I don't
know if this Oh, this is him implying
that he actually hasn't sat down with
his attorneys or her attorneys. It could
just be him saying, "Can I have
permission to say this on stream?"
Yeah.
Yeah. What down with your attorneys? I
don't know if this is him implying that
he actually hasn't sat down with his
attorneys or her attorneys. It could
just be him saying, "Can I have
permission to say this on stream?" Yes.
And then he has to like think. He's
like, "Wait, is that is that
Yeah, I'm just asking for permission."
Oh, no. I know he's considering what bit
of an assumption here, but I'm so
curious if Lauren is the one that's
quarterbacking this
case
because he he he was so close to the
truth. Huh? Huh? You know, maybe
maybe Trump just lost the
election. Or Hold on, hold on. Wait. I
just had a thought. I just had a
thought.
George Soros is probably actually
quarterbacking this whole thing. He
asked her a question. Do you mind if I
make a public statement about the case?
And she answered that statement in one
minute. How did she know the answer to
that? So, I imagine that she'd probably
text or email her lawyer and ask, "Is it
okay if this guy makes this statement
with regards to Destiny or whatever?" Or
it might just be, "What if somebody else
has asked if they could mention that
they spoke to her lawyers or something?"
What if she just knows that you can't
actually tell them no that it's like no
you can't talk about this
anywhere. I don't know. I don't know.
Does that look good? Hey, could I s
could I tell somebody that I talked to
your lawyers? No. Shut the up. I don't
know if you can I don't know if you can
do that. But they answer
instantly.
How? It's so funny. It's so funny. How
is chat? They just all take like Q's,
right? They all take Q's like little
drones. Susi sus
susi
sus. This is the you he that used to
make him uh fun to This is the [__] that
used to make him fun to watch, but with
the wool pulled back, it's just so
cringe at Jar. I know. I know. But
here's the thing. in a lot of other
cases. Now, I can't say for sure with
like uh the Mr. Girl thing and a lot of
these other cases, I think like with the
election stuff, with the Trump stuff,
it's like he's usually arguing on the
side of right, right? Like he is
actually making like morally correct
arguments. He he used to do that quite
often. He would make like the morally
correct argument. And then you could
say, well, he's offensive and he's rude
and he's like bordering on like um on
being psychopathic, but he's doing it
for the sake of good. And now that sake
of good thing is just totally gone,
right? And he's like probably logically
in the wrong in a in a lot of these
cases as well. It's like he he can't
stand on like the logical footing. He
can't stand on the moral high ground.
He's got like no
footing. Uh Mark Carney, I agree with
the first statement. I probably I agree.
I don't think Max is like a bad person.
Um I would agree that he's a better
person than Destiny
2, for sure.
I don't know if I could just say like
blanket Max is a good person with like
the story and stuff, but like I I don't
know. I I talked to Max,
so I I don't think Max is like uh I do
think I do think I would qualify him as
like a far better person than Destiny.
Obviously, this is them explicitly
saying they're falsifying a claim of
witnesses.
Wait, how is it saying
that? He's like, I don't see it, but you
have me intrigued. Could you You're
telling me there's a Kraken here. Can
you point the I don't see the Kraken,
but I do want to know. She sat down with
the attorneys. He's asking Chill to let
a stream know. Well, no. I understand.
That's what I am interpreting this as.
But why was she able to answer in the
affirmative in one minute here? Would
she have actually cleared it with her
lawyer first, though? I thought about
that. But what what what would that even
look like? Do you think that if you ask
a lawyer, hey, just checking if any of
the witnesses want to make public
statements about any of the things
they've said with you, are they cool for
that? Do you think any lawyer would give
a blanket yes on that? No shot. 0%
chance. Because
remember, attorney client privilege, and
I imagine that extends to witnesses
because your attorney is an extension of
yourself. Um, attorney client privilege
is one of the things that I don't get
access to. I I don't know what you tell
your attorney. So the the idea that she
would get a blanket authorization from
her attorney for people to leak what
they conferred about or what they spoke
about. That's I don't believe that.
That's crazy. Does he think Wait, wait,
wait. Does he think Pixie's lawyers like
consulted with me for like strategy or
something? Is that what he thinks? He
thinks the the legal experts came to me
and were like, "Hey, we we actually
don't know what to do. Mr. Streamer
streamer man, could you could you give
us like a little bit of strategy on
this? Could you tell us like what's
going on? We don't really know.
No,
no. They took a statement for me. They
took They took a statement from me. What
does he think that they Why Why wouldn't
I? And by the way, I don't think I would
have said anything in that statement
that I wouldn't have said on my public
stream. I don't remember exactly what I
said, but I'm pretty confident I didn't
say anything in that statement, whatever
we were talking about, that I haven't
already said on
stream. What's up, big Aaron? How's it
going? Welcome.
Welcome. Oh,
wait. Wait. Could that be it? Oh, hold
on. I don't know. Wait. Oh, wait. Hold
on. Oh, god. Wait. The conspiracy brain.
Wait.
Do you mind if I say I sat down with
your attorneys? And she says, "Yeah,
sure. What day? What for?" Exactly. Did
she misread this as him saying, "Do you
mind if I sit down with your attorneys?"
And she was asking, "Sh Oh, that would
explain the instant response
time."
Oh, wait. So, do you think this means he
was She could have interpreted as him
asking for a second
meeting. Oh. Oh.
I just wanted to say it
today.
Oh, I almost don't even want to make fun
of how he is because I I like that he's
just going in the totally like wrong.
It's very funny to me that he's like
totally making things up. I almost don't
want to mock him on stream. I almost
don't want to like be like, "No, no, no,
no. It's probably more boring and like
oriented towards reality. I just want to
see where he'll go to. Where how far
will he run in the wrong
direction means he didn't sit down with
them, but he wants to lie that they
don't streng. That's that's what it
looks like. Now, maybe he met with him
one time and he wanted to and she
thought he was asking to meet with him a
second
time. Well, actually, wait, that's easy
to figure out. You should subpoena his
logs. I already requested that in
Discovery, I believe. I doubt they'll
produce it for me since they don't seem
to be giving anything else.
But I think that's one of the reasons
why he was spooked. Not because of any
public threat I've made, but because he
would have to actually provide proof for
the things that he's been doing. And I
imagine what he's probably doing is
running. Uh if Destiny wants like access
to any of that stuff by the way, uh I
think I could just say like
um as long as the identities are
protected, I would I will make a
statement and then I think that would
let him subpoena me,
right? I will say I
explain No, no, no. I'm not going to say
that. Oh, yeah. I know. No. I'm going to
save that one. Deleting all of his
evidence and actually deleting all of
his logs and actually trying to hide as
much as he can. Nope. But he thinks
because he's in Canada that he's safe
from it all.
Uh yeah, I think I just would be I don't
know. I haven't been
served. I I would be. Yeah, but I
haven't deleted anything. It's like all
We're just We're just chilling, man.
It's my guess. That's why he doesn't
want to. Just don't oppose this. Just
let this gag order go or let the uh this
stuff being filed under what is it?
Protect like the protective order go
through. Just don't oppose the
protective order and then you'd gain the
right to subpoena me. I think I think
that's how it works, right?
Be officially in this
case. Exhibit B. Hold on. Let me let me
pull up exhibit B here. Bro, this is the
um great link. This is the this is the
clip I got sent and I just like I was
like almost crying laughing. Clearly
heroic individual's identity. Um so let
me see. Let me just see. Oh wow. Uh I
don't know who this could possibly You
know
what? I'm glad that they protected this
person's identity. They could really be
in a lot of trouble. This person's
apparently been threatened. Whoever this
person is could have been in a lot of
trouble if their identity was exposed.
Now, now it's funny that he's laughing.
Joking.
Remember, for initially, I was basically
a serial. Okay. Then when the case was
filed, well, nobody nobody ever said
that. We're always very
clear. It's not serial rap.
Habitual consent violator is kind of
what we like to go. Single law firm, let
alone multiple law firms uh that I had
retained for this. And then it was when
it took me too long to respond. It was
because I was representing myself
because I was so arrogant that I thought
I was a master lawyer. And then when my
You do think you're a master lawyer. You
literally in multiple times in this
thing have said like, "No, obviously I
know way better than her lawyers." Legal
team finally responded. They were inept
and they were bad at their job because
they waited to run the clock down to
respond and apparently was a bad
lawyer. Nobody has ever called Andy B a
bad lawyer. Literally nobody has ever
said that. I he is hallucinating like
commentary that happened. Show me
anybody who has said the things that
Desi is saying happened. And then when
her legal team showed up, they were big
shots. Hot shots is what was said cuz
they done so many different types of law
on all by
who? Dude, who ever said Pixie's lawyers
were hot
shots? He's just he's just like
blatantly lying. He is literally just
rewriting reality. And again, um, for
anybody who like knows what's going on,
anybody who's like looked into this at
all, it's just embarrassing, right? It's
just for the clapping seals is again he
is he is like what you need to
understand about this audience in this
stream when he does it is he is like a
magician. Okay. And what do we remember
the uh is it the illusionist? No, no,
no, no, no. the prestige. I think I
think it's the prestige where they say
the thing you need to understand about
the audience when they sit down is they
want to be fooled, right? Everybody in
that audience wants to be
fooled. And so he can give as long as he
goes makes a puff of smoke appear
somewhere else and he gives some thing
that isn't even a that's just not not
it's not real at all. It's just an
illusion, right? as long as he can give
them that, they'll look over at it and
even if he's really badly stuffing a
pigeon into his pants, okay, they'll
keep looking over at the puff of smoke
because they they want to be tricked.
They want to believe that magic is real.
They want to believe that Destiny didn't
do these things. And they will take any
justification for that that they can get
anything. Anything. They're they're
grasping for anything. It doesn't have
to be real or tangible. Daddy, please
give me any story that makes the bad
things go away. Rico was coming. It was
going to be a big deal, right? And then
my case was hopeless and I was getting
buried. The lawyer from Puerto Rico is
coming. You better be scared. Blah blah
blah. And then it started to change to,
okay, he has highpowered lawyers.
They've defended master across the
globe. That was the first thing we said
when we found out who your lawyers were.
I don't know where any of the other
stuff's coming from. I tweeted about
Andy B being your lawyer the second he
signed on Prohawk Viche. Unfortunately,
her lawyers are getting bad faith
attacked and now everybody's getting
intimidated. Look at the changing. And
now
now this fat uh loser Yep. Oh, I guess
he's not part of the case. So, can we
say more about him? This fat loser,
right, is a Oh, isn't it funny how inept
her legal team? And by the way, I'm just
giving you because I do pre-watch the
feature. Okay, just so you know, the
spin that people are going to try to do.
I'm going to go through this. This is
going to be a seven hour video on my
YouTube. Okay, I'm going to go through
this case from start to finish cuz holy
[__] All right, but the spin by all the
end of this is going to be Destiny only
won this case on a technicality because
he had highowered lawyers and he buried
this poor girl um under a mountain of
No, the the spin would be that they
wouldn't have been able to find evidence
of you sending it after the fact. That
might be that you didn't send it after
Cardi, but like morally you literally
signed an
affidavit. By the
way, give me what? Another month and
this guy wants to race. We can race.
I'll race
him. Wait, wait, wait. Hold on. I need
to get some donations or something out
of this. I don't know if I want to show
my face somewhere. I could like record
it. Yeah, that's what I'd do. I get like
a GoPro and record it. I'll go for a
run. Vexacious motion or litigation.
That's going to be the
He's right. There's going to be so much
hope if Destiny comes out on top of this
case. No, I I've literally said already
that like they might not be able to find
it. He already signed the affidavit.
Where's the cope? Hold on. The cope is
that he didn't sign an affidavit
admitting to the behavior directly. He
sent that non-consensually. That's not
even like that's just factually admitted
to the case. That's not that's not an
element of contention that he sent
non-consensually is not an element of
contention. This is just about how much
Pixie should get in compensation for it.
Where do you think Where do you think
like any of the moral condemnation you
should have should come from? Is it
based on how much money one of them
gets? Are
you very embarrassing for some of these
people? I I feel like they might not
even know that Destiny signed a
statement saying that. Like they might
actually be too dumb. The fire child
person, the who is it? Noxen.
All of these people are like just too
minded to actually go and just read any
document themselves without the Destiny
spin.
Crazy. What what people will try to sell
as the um ending narrative for all of
this
anyway. The name is redacted. Yes, the
name is redacted. The avatar is not
redacted.
And again, like it's funny just because
of the context of all of this and
because I can bear it psychologically
and financially. Um, but like it's funny
because you're a terrible person. That's
why it's funny. It's it's just funny.
It's all funny. Also, like Yeah, it's
just funny. These are It's double funny
now. It's It truly is disgusting, right?
Because again, this is a federal case.
These are serious claims.
A federal judge is going to have to sit
here and read. We do a magistrate
hearing
tomorrow. Okay. The resources of the
state. Listen, lawyers get paid. They
don't give a Okay. My legal team, I'm
sure they're happy. They get their
money. I don't know about J. Yeah. And
he's Andy's getting a Lambo out of this.
Legal team. I'm sure it's a good family
favor. They're cashing it on.
Um but like it's just a waste of like
the state's time of the federal
government's time. So he's very
concerned about the state. Listen guys,
it's actually not that bad for me. I can
bear it. But the state is strapped for
resources. And the the state, it's all
about the state. We're so it's soed up
that the state is losing its resources.
There's like a judge and a court and
they're they're wasting all of their
time. I can I can afford it. I can
totally afford it. Pay no attention.
Okay? Please pay no attention to the
fact that I'm trying to totally scam my
audience with a $400 knife right
now. All I'm saying is I might pay 400
bucks if this comes from an autograph
from Andrew Breler. If you can get me an
autographed knife, an autographed signed
certificate of authenticity. Andrew
Andrew Breler. I'm buying a Lambo based
on Destiny selling these knives because
he needs some liquid cash now. Let's go.
By the way, he fought over extending 10
pages, which he knew would get approved.
He also spent five, what was it? Five
different documents trying to argue that
Pixie shouldn't be able to get a the
Kiwi Farms video taken down. Yeah. Yeah.
Very cool. You love to see it. Waste.
And it's just like a joke to all of
these people.
[Laughter]
Now, it was going to be like, let's be
real. It was going to be obvious who it
was just from the um like it literally
No, it doesn't have to be obvious.
That's a lie. I can't watch his watching
him and other people talk about this
like the people
that it doesn't have to No, it doesn't
have to be obvious. No, it's not
obvious. Uh meanwhile, we go back. Well,
how far do we have to go back? Right
here. Was this the Was this the time
stamp I had? Oh, somewhere around here.
Wasn't it right here where he was
talking about just how obvious it was?
So, he goes, "No, no, it's not obvious.
It's not obvious. Further information
after defendant publicly called for his
death on the defendant. It's not
obvious. Why would you? Okay, so it's
either So it's it's one of two
people. Attached to his exhibit B is a
true and correct copy of his
communication to me expressing his fear
defendant. Let's see if we can figure
out who this one
is. It's not obvious. It's not obvious.
It doesn't have to be obvious. He's
probably going to try to argue that all
of it should be filed under a seal or
something. But realistically, I don't
need my online pseudonym protected. I'm
I'm Dude, I'm already public enemy
number one, he was reading two seconds
into this document. Even when things
weren't referring to me, his entire chat
was saying my name, talking about what a
piece of I am. I don't need protection
for my online pseudonym. That's not what
I
need. That hate me are so brainbroken in
their analysis. It's so funny listening
to the crazy legal theories that they
spin to try to make it so they're like,
"Actually, this filing Oh, wait, hold
on. He'll have an example for us, right?
He'll have an example of where like some
crazy legal theory was spun that makes
absolutely no sense that makes him like
100% guilty. Surely I've done this
somewhere, right? Or is he just going to
actually like make that up? Never
reference a clip, never reference
anything real. He's going to totally
make it up about me,
right? I thought we didn't we I thought
I thought he went through a whole arc
with these people where he was trying to
teach them how that was a really bad
thing to do. You should have an example,
right? You shouldn't just get to without
looking at any clip, without looking at
any example say this person does a
thing. No, it doesn't have to be
obvious. That's a lie. Their analysis is
so funny listening to the crazy legal
theories that they spin to try to make
it so they're like, "Actually, this
filing is really good. This filing
actually is is hold on. I can give a
crazy legal theory. I can do it." Uh, I
thought for a little bit that that um
distributor or whatever the the the
adjective that's used in
USC 6 USC
6851 whatever this was uh disclose I
thought disclose possibly possibly might
have meant uh so publish that publish
could have meant like maybe old links
right I think there are people who have
made that argument I think under some
circumstances that argument could
actually work. But now I believe that
that argument probably or make
accessible that that might not be the
case that you might not be able to argue
that to get to stay within Cardi. But
hey, that's that's look I can do it and
he can at
all really good for them. You got but I
don't even know if that I don't even
know if that was
um I don't even know if I like knew
that. I just I think I I read a couple
cases where basically they talked about
how links worked and stuff and I was
like, "Oh, if they view it this way and
this is like um the way they've they've
decided these cases, then that might not
hold up. Watch like the next minute."
It's everything these people say is so
stupid. Like the the quotes like
referenced earlier on.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But I'm
sorry. It's like it's just very very
very they're like not saying the name,
they're protecting the name. I click on
this my but like realistically like you
realize they've done this to like five
other people in this case, right? I
could maybe understand maybe but like I
think those people consented to their
screen names being used like I I think
those screen names were like introduced
previously, right? So they did it to
Abby. I think the ABMC screen name the
ABMC screen name was used. It was in the
defendants disclosures,
right? Pixie disclosures. I don't know
if you say defendants disclosures there,
but like that name was used already. So
five. Did they do that to like bunch of
other people? I could understand it
happening once, but if you're making
mistake after mistake, I'm sorry. You
should recuse yourself or or ask the
tell the plaintiff. He's very concerned
for all of these people actually. He's
just incredibly concerned. You're not
suitable for representing them in a case
of this caliber or or in any federal
case at all. stick to I don't know what
law they do in Puerto Rico or whatever
local jurisdiction you're that's like
where that's like where all of the the
Browns live, right? All the disgusting
trash browns in Puerto Rico. Whatever
kind of disgusting trash brown person
law they do in Puerto Rico, disgusting
Puerto Ricans under immigration sounded
like the what she specialized. Just do
do that. Stick to that.
I there's no reason to suspect or like I
don't need um I've said that to Pixie,
but I I told Pixie I was like I
literally said, "Hey, I'm going to talk
about that on stream." And then I said
it live like publicly, right? So
realistically, I want my my identity
protected, but I don't need like um the
the pseudonym protected is whatever,
right?
Yeah. Like what he's saying here, and
again, I know these guys live in a
separate world. This is child's play.
This is not how the real world works,
right?
Why do protective orders exist?
I like I wish, bro, I thought
every time I hear this guy say
something, I'm just like more
embarrassed that I ever thought he had
anything poignant to say at all. Why do
protective orders exist? Men don't show
up to court in a guy fox mask saying,
"Your honor, it's okay that they know my
video game name, but I would like to
protect my real life name." No. In real
life, in the big boy world, if you want
to go to court, then you your name is on
the line. That's it. It has to be. Your
your reputation is on the line. Your
testimony. Wait, but the court would
know the name. I can't not show the name
to the court. The credibility of you as
a person is on the line because now
you're in the big boy world. Okay. This
isn't a real You're not making a real
argument. The court knows. There is no
legal downside for you in my name being
protected in public filings. Why is he
pretending that that is the case? Sorry.
I Every time I ask why, it's because he
is not making a real argument. He is
pretending to be right. He's pretending
to be so the clapping seals can go.
Sorry. Yeah. The the clapping seals will
go. Yeah. Yeah. There's no reason for
him to protect it. Objective orders need
justification to prove a reason for it.
Uh this man has a massive platform and
he's called for my death. He actually
admits to calling for my death earlier
in this stream.
Yeah, that's the justification. It's
literally in the document. He's read it
now. I've read it multiple times. Patty
XD, are you confused? Are you
lost? Do you have a where your brain
matter where your gray matter should be?
Is that what's going on right now? Are
you okay? Do we need a neurosurgeon for
you to remove that directly from your
gray
matter? Plaintiff initially filed this
case after demanding $15 million for me.
All right. You don't get to make those
types of supporting claims behind a fat
video game avatar. Either stand tall.
Hey, and that's just the cheeks. The
avatar is very good-looking. Actually,
the avatar is just the cheeks. Okay. The
court aren't aware of these
allegations. Oh, that person is totally
disingenuous. That person should just
go, right? That person's like actually
just a brain dead. Totally brain dead.
Jesus
Christ. It's literally in the document.
It's in this document that he's
reading. What are we doing? What are we
What are we doing on what you're saying?
Him calling your avatar fat is so
telling that Kelly won. Kelly did win.
Kelly totally owned this guy again is
very
funny. Dude,
Kelly owns this guy. He's like, just
call Why Why don't you go after Kelly,
bro? This is Listen, why am I the
target? Why am I the target for
everybody? Okay, Nicholas Dorio, go
after Queen and Destiny, go after Kelly
Jean. Okay, I didn't call you fat. Stay
away from my calling me fat. [__] Uh,
you what are you doing? Go after Kelly.
She's the one talking [__] about your
looks. I even I even say look, I don't
want to call another guy fat. Okay, I
got a I got a bit of a gut going. Okay,
I don't I'm not going to call another
dude fat. That Well, unless it's Nick,
but that's just cuz Nick is very jolly
looking anyway. Sorry. Or do a big boy
protective order and super save all your
or whatever. This half in half out
is what is a big boy protective order
and super save all
your what is that is are we doing a
little boy protective
order?
What? Wait, is there What's a big boy
protective order and super save all
your what? I Is this not a big boy
protective order? Is this not a
Is this Is this not a big boy protective
order? I'm so confused. Stand tall on
what you're saying.
Or do a big boy protective order and
super save all your or whatever. This
half in half out
is I think he means don't use screen
names. Yeah, the protective order. Hold
on. Just to be clear, I'll put my name
in if there's a protective order, right?
You can't give an affidavit with your
screen name.
You can't do that. You have to have your
legal name on an affidavit.
Yeah, I have no issue disclosing my
identity at all as long as I know it's
protected. That's literally Does he
think Does anybody think that I'm not
going to disclose my identity? I've said
that on stream multiple times. As long
as they can prove to me that they can uh
withhold withhold my identity from the
public and make it not okay for him to
say it, then I'll I'm in. I'm
good. What? Who's confused on
that? That's literally what this
protective order is setting up. Well,
for other people, too.
But you said public things about him and
he can say whatever is public.
Okay. Well, oh my god, the cognitive
victims in here. Jesus. I should I have
to stop reading these chats. You guys
are I mean you guys like get off on
being This is like you've you've like
actually absorbed Destiny's public
humiliation fetish and you guys try to
go in and act it in other chats by
acting It's very disgusting. Please
don't include me in your kink. It's very
gross. Please off. Stay plugged up
somewhere else. Back to the cave. Get
out of here. Let her know. I was like,
"Hey, just so you know, that should have
definitely been censored. That would
have been insane not to censor it. If it
wasn't somebody who had spoken publicly,
right?" So, yeah, that like if I had
spoken publicly on it, this is me asking
to um speak publicly on it, right? I'm
just going to say like, "Oh, I'm going
to say that on stream." Oh, boy. Can
witnesses not remain anonymous?
Obviously, the filers reveal themselves,
but I feel the witnesses should show up
some protection if it was more. No,
there's exceptional circumstances where
they can be anonymous, like in child
crime cases.
Maybe Oh. What?
What? This guy's got a massive platform.
He's talking about killing me. He's
telling people that they should kill me.
That's I feel like that's a pretty
exceptional case, maybe. But no, you
have a right to because imagine if if
like 10 people came out to support a
Pixie, but they were all anonymous. How
am I supposed to defend myself against
claims? Um, how am I supposed to defend
myself against claims if I don't know
who's making
any any accusations against me? You
can't do that. No, he would know. He
would know. You're just not allowed to
disclose it. You would know. He's not
that stupid. He's not actually that
stupid.
Hey, Electus, thank you for the new sub.
Let's go. Three months. Thank you very
much. Thank you. Thank
you. There just I just don't want it
disclosed publicly and I want him to be
under penalty if he discloses it
publicly. Right? That's what I
want. Pro tip, make sure to call the
magistrate a magistrate judge. In my
state, we have at least one magistrate
who specifically said at a silly she
wants to be called a magistrate judge.
I'll probably say your honor for
everything. I'll ask my
um all the guidance on that. But I
sorry, I I had a a little Well, they
should have to reveal themselves to you,
but just not to the public. Oh, sure.
cinema. You can do that easily. That's
called filing under seal. But the
problem is plaintiff plaintiff's council
that I don't know. I I don't know where
they practiced law at or what they do or
if they're even real lawyers. I know
that they're super ass about me
criticizing their inability to
understand the English language or basic
rules of federal civil procedure. I know
that that makes them very assigned, but
this is unacceptable behavior. Like you
should be cringing. Oh, sure. Sure. I
meant like he'll have the ability to
subpoena me through his lawyers. Yeah.
Oh, I I actually thought it was just
Listen, if I if I if stuff for me could
be filed under seal, I'd be fine with
that. Right now, that some music school
dropout online is is reading through
your court filings and can see that you
are clearly incapable and doing a
disservice to both the federal court.
Why is he so racist? I don't know why he
keeps pointing out that this judge is
from Puerto Rico is very weird. Puerto
Rico. What? Puerto Ricans are Americans,
right? Aren't Puerto Ricans Americans
and to the client that you're supposedly
representing? You're not qualified for
the case. You're in way the over your
head and no amount. I just want to point
out in case anybody was curious if
um just, you know, a fun little fun
little thing. Fun fact. Fun
fact, fun fact.
Okay. He um he said earlier, "Oh, I
can't even watch this guy. It's so
disgusting. It's so disgusting. I can't
even watch this guy. What's this? What's
this? I'm up there. I'm up there with
one of the all-time greats. I bumped Vos
out. Vos, you are number three. I am
number two. I am almost comparing to
Hassan. Now, I understand Hassan holds a
special place in his heart. Okay, I
understand Hassan holds a special place,
but I am number two now. All right,
maybe one day we'll get there.
Good times. Good times. Oh, wrong one. I
think this one. This one. Yes. No amount
of lawyers at your firm flying to Texas
for cancer or pneumonia sicknesses that
you're having is an excuse for like the
disgusting negligence that you've shown
or ineptitude that you've shown handling
this case in my opinion. But you know,
who the [__] am I? I guess except the
defendant. I guess in a way what I
really You know what? What I really mean
to say, let me be more concise. What I
really mean to say is thank you
plaintiff's counsel. Thank you. That's
what I mean to say. Truly, thank you.
Truly, thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Make sure that next time you file the
request for a page extension so you can
have 20 pages to write about how mad you
are about the mean things I say about
you. I hope they do file for page
extensions to go just to 11 pages so
that Destiny gets ass again and tells
Andy B to go write up a uh opposing
motion. Okay, Andy, go write up an
opposing motion. I know it's going to
cost me another 10 grand, but Andy,
you're worth it. Do not let them file
with extra Oh, they're filing with extra
pages anyway. Well, you know what? It
I'm going to sell another $400 knife to
my fans and it'll be
okay. I'm sorry. This is just so funny
to
me. Where is it?
He refers to me as a disgusting and
repeatedly accuses me of grabbing random
people to perjure themselves. Defendant
accuses plaintiffs council me of bad
faith arguments explicitly lying and
abuse of the court system. He's been
Hold on. See, he's going to touch on it
now, right? He won't just he won't go
past granding grabbing random people to
perjure themselves, right? He won't just
um he won't just skip that one again.
telling his followers that we have no
understanding of the federal rules of
civil procedure because uh we allegedly
did not adhere to proper procedures by
filing redacted declarations of the
witness and then the stuff about Lauren
opposed on Kiwi Farms the defendant
attack Lauren Hayden a friend a
potential witness okay I do like I do
like you know that's a fair point about
Kiwi Farms they'll definitely the judge
will go wait hold on you get this from
Kiwi Farms
no that is a great defense this evidence
is on Kiwi farms. Oh, we have to we have
to strike that from the recorded as an
individual likely to come to information
lies about and talk about how he would
like to get her dispar because she
doesn't support the plaintiff. Yes,
we've read this. We've read this court
and then he did and he made you go. Yep.
The and the mag. We're back to going to
this this whole thing.
lol is expressed fear for providing any
further information after publicly
called his death on the YouTube channel.
Keep in mind again how disgusting this
is, right? This guy has streamed for
months. This guy has streamed for months
covering all this, but he won't stand up
and testify
for for a plaintiff. Just want So it's
only to make money. Actually, I think
this is actually right now that I think
about it. I do want to protect it from
Destiny. I don't trust that he wouldn't
try to leak it. He's actually expressed
publicly, don't you know? He said as
soon as he gets my information, he would
leak it immediately. And then he got
someone else's information, leak that
immediately. Okay. I actually do think a
protective order is appropriate. I trust
Andy B way more than Destiny. Okay. Andy
B would never leak my name. This Destiny
guy, he's a shady character. He's a
shady character just to make money off
of this because he's farming this the
same way you farmed anybody else
involved with
this. Couldn't possibly be that I find
you disgusting, your behavior
disgusting. The fact that I once
supported you disgusting and that makes
this content both interesting to me and
like uh I don't know, just it's just
interesting to me. Yeah, I like covering
this stuff. I like knowing it. I don't
like you. You're a bad person. You're
somebody I thought was a good person.
like a super helpful person to like
society. I was mind read and now I'm
like, "Oh, I should make other people
understand that you're like a horrible
person." Be good.
What's up, Tan? The three other
potential witnesses also believe the
defendants committed crimes against them
by disclosing intimate images of them
without their consent, but they were
afraid of pursuing legal action because
of how he has publicly harassed and
assaulted me and anyone who has
supported me, including my council. They
were like, "You have to include this. He
attacked us too, remember?
I mean, you're reporting the news.
Should journalists have to testify in a
trial they're covering? Yeah, exactly.
It's just coverage. It's just coverage.
Okay. That's all it is. Three of these
witnesses have expressed to me fear that
their physical well-being could even be
put at risk if they attempt to pursue
justice. Oh my god.
Patch here to exhibit C is a trunk copy
of my conversation with one of those
witnesses whose screen name is length
defendant.
exhibit.
Let's see. We already looked at all
these, right?
This one. Hold on. I think I saw a clip
of this one, too. This a Twitter
message. Steven Bonell has abused his
position of power and community to gain
favor and harass people in the past. I
find his actions and terrifying. I will
never feel comfortable being a witness
in this case against Steven unless my
identity is protected. I fear for my
family, friends, and my current and
future careers. without protection. I am
almost certain I will receive harassment
and doxing from his
community. Is this a single DM with no?
This is a single DM, right? Because
unless they white boxed all their
responses here. It looks like they got
one message from this person.
Huh? Oh, a text or a text. I'm sorry,
not a
DM. I also like Yeah, I like how there's
no date on it.
Wait, what is
today?
Monday, Friday, on the 30th. When did we
file our Was it on the 30th? On the
30th. Do you think she asked? I I bet
this is fake. That's pretty weird. Uh I
wouldn't be shocked if they talked on
one platform and then said, "Could you
text us through like another platform if
you don't want uh any of this stuff
exposed or something?" I don't know why
it's just the one
text. Yeah, I have no idea. I bet this
is a fake
message. I don't believe this. It reads
like a and and and clearly opposing
council and plaintiff are dumb enough to
fake something in the stupidest way
possible. I just Yeah, I look at this
and I'm like, yeah, I'm guessing that
that's like sent through some other
platform, people not wanting to give
away their identity or
something. I have no idea. Um I haven't
seen anything fake so far. I don't know
why he's like ex I don't know why he
just immediately goes to the most
conspiratorial explanation.
Nice typed out message with proper
capital. Yeah. Is this one? Yeah. I have
I have no record of any of these people.
They didn't forward us any like
unredacted filings at all. They didn't
send us any information about any of
these people. There's literally nothing.
I don't know if that would be true.
Destiny is just suggesting they're
committing perjury. Yeah. Well, he's
done it multiple times, right? That is
again him saying they're faking evidence
right now.
Again, by the way, these lawyers who
apparently are total feel like when
Destiny does uh defame them and say that
they're like perjuring themselves
publicly on his platform with like
millions of people who could potentially
see it across Twitter or like they they
clip his channel, it gets put up
everywhere, right? There there are like
millions of people who view Destiny's
content.
And he does these things and he goes,
"Yeah, no, no. It couldn't possibly hurt
their
reputation." Brother, you're like, you
are just totally you're in conspiracy
mode making things up about these people
with no evidence. Of course, it could
hurt
them. Yeah. Like, who says Steven
Bonell? Seriously, somebody's saying
that it's like an affidavit, but if you
want to have them fill out an affidavit
or to fill one out and sign
it, then have them do that. fill out an
affidavit and sign it. Not an affidavit.
This is a stage. This is a stage text,
though.
Also, you're filing a redacted. Why are
you filing redacted screen names? If
you're filing a redacted version, why
are you not even putting their name
whose screen name
is? Almost every individual I
communicated with expressed not only
their disgust for defendants's actions,
but also their reluctance to speak up
publicly due to their concern and fear
your defendant retaliating against them.
Why didn't you get all of these
statements then prior to filing the
complaint? Is that something you have to
do? I just don't think that's a
requirement sign today. Nice.
Why are there no previous texts in the
Yeah, there's statements during
discovery. No. Well, you can I think
like you should get you should get your
in the row like in in a row early in the
case. Like they probably would have been
asking these people for statements. I
would imagine if these people were in
January saying I am too scared to like
have my name on the record. This guy
scares me. Then there was probably some
further discussion that happened like
hey I know you're like afraid but we can
protect you. You should give us a
statement. And then eventually some of
those people would have gone away,
right? like this is obviously the
natural like progression of events, but
he's pretending that that's like
unthinkable. Doesn't want to put the
actual natural progression of events
into his audience's head because then
they would have, you know, some tools to
actually accurately evaluate the
case. Yes, Latigious. Yeah, latigious
gamer. Exactly. Aren't they explaining
why they didn't get the statements in
this very motion that he is currently
reading? Yes,
exactly. in that screenshot. Like I
said, I think that
um the Destiny Vars database, isn't it
super popular to file this motion the
day before the hearing, too? Means your
lawyers don't have a chance to drop it.
Yeah, I it was intentional, too, because
I think normally um I don't know if
these motions actually affect the
hearing. I think these motions, so if
I'm not mistaken, I think these motions
and the I I'll check right now, but my
recollection was that these motions and
the things that went with
them, these motions and like the the
other documents that went with them were
actually not filed as a part of the
preliminary injunction hearing. So,
we'll see. Text of the proposed order,
text of the proposed order, text of the
proposed order. We'll
see. So, this one's Jacqueline Beera.
This one is Jacqueline
Becca and this one is Jacqueline Becker.
So these are all in the US District
Court. These are not I don't believe
these orders would be a part
of support of
declaration
492. Hold on.
Uh, some of them might be. No, some of
them might be going into that
case. It's
possible it's filing under
seal. There might be something with
regards to Abby that needs to be filed
under seal, which is the uh actually the
text message that we are hoping we get
him get a chance to see him read.
Do
I Let me get a drink.
Oh, sorry. I went I went to the wrong
time stamp. This was meant to just show
when he's like when he's whining there.
My bad. Normally, um, it takes What are
you saying? There's no way to know.
There's no way to possibly know. And
then he's like, "Oh, this is obviously
like Queen or JC responses." And they
had until the sixth, but they made sure
to get this one in tonight. They got
this one in on
time.
Problem. So, they just got it in on
time. He's complaining that they got it
in on time. Okay.
Why does any of this
anything under seal
Plaintiff requests that the seal remain
in place for the duration of litigation,
including any appeals to ensure ongoing
protection of the witnesses. This
duration is consistent with the need to
prevent further emotional psychological
harm plaintiff and the individuals
referenced in her declaration as
supported by do Williams v.
Williams. What do you think this case
looked like?
I don't know.
No way. We're buying pacer documents for
another case.
Cool. He's
got this person. This person's home or
pliff has some recollection of the
events. They became aware of some
encounter. Could not recall everything
that happened. Pliff had never been with
a female before and had any interest in
being with a female. No other thing.
Jesus Christ. Noticing a phone in
Williams hand that night. PL asked
Williams following morning she wanted to
place Williams probably she did indeed
record sex between the two of them told
her to delete the video. Williams
falsely told plaintiff she had nothing
to worry about as her face was not on
the video. The reassurance meant little
as Williams said she was not going to
delete the video but instead would keep
it in the vault. Pliff again told
Williams. The plaintiff would feel
better if it was deleted than the video.
She refused to do so. Discover Williams
not to delete the video in or about May
3rd 2023. At the time, Williams casually
mentioned the wife and um of her
boyfriend
Brad and listened in a state of shock as
she realized video of the nonential acts
being passed around. The Mississippi
Highway Patrol were both at the time.
Otherwise, this what happened.
Are we getting to a point
or you believe Pixie's Puerto Rican
lawyer filed on time? The audacity is
just dismissed.
Are we done with everything for my These
motions probably could be referred to
the magistrate judge. Magistrates handle
a lot of pre-trial stuff. Oh, maybe
motion for leave if I redacted evidence
in support of the Oh, we have evidence
from this anonymous person. Oh, boy. We
do. Okay, this is the witness. I really
want to find it cuz he has said
previously that this is totally made up
and there is no evidence of this. So, I
do want to see his reaction to this.
This is like one of most Yeah, I'm going
be honest. I didn't expect this to turn
into open anti- Puerto Rican racism.
Well,
well, punctuality is a construction for
him by whiteness.
Ah, he is becoming conservative before
our very eyes. He's becoming red pill
and conservative. Listen, Walter.
Walter, you better lock your down with a
Fresh and Fit podcast. Walter, okay?
Because it's about to be Myron and
Stephen. Myin and Esteban. All right. No
more Walter. Walter's going to be out.
Myin and Estabbon running the Fresh and
Fit podcast cutting these down to size.
Keeping the whole case alive. This is
the big one,
boys. Okay. Correctly moves this court
for leave to submit evidence in redacted
form and believe to file under seal the
unreacted evidence in support of the
declaration of this person who was filed
on May 2nd 2025. Plaintiff files this
announced evidence support
decoration. Hold on what why isn't he
reading? There's no way this is just
quiet. Why does he just read? In the
instant case, good cause is unclear as
the exhibit contains highly sensitive
details of private sexually acts
implicating the substantial rights of
the declar and other individuals. Public
disclosure of their identities will
expose the dementilation help
violations. By the way, sex tapes all
the time. He thinks I don't know the
girls in them, but videos of him [__]
Oh, thank okay. We censored her name.
This doesn't even exist. and Pixie like
Lympho. He just sent me another one over
there. Why not post the the this person
says we don't know who this is. Okay,
even though they accidentally
also
Okay, so I just want I want to point out
for all the totally in here because I
know you guys watch you can't get
enough. Okay, I love you. I love you.
You'll figure it out eventually. This
person apparently in November of 2023
before ever possibly knowing that these
videos could exist describes videos that
would later videos and audio that would
later be leaked, okay, to that would
later be leaked onto the internet would
cause a massive scandal. They do it a
full year before those videos were
leaked to the internet.
They somehow tapped into the
schizosphere and made up the fact that
Destiny had these videos and would send
them to
people a full year before we actually
knew in the public in any way that those
videos have been
leaked. Um and and Destiny saying this
is just a lot. There's no way that this
this just didn't happen. This just
didn't apparently she's um she's just
psychic. Apparently she's a psychic and
this is not Rose. No, this is in support
of the declaration of
AbbyMC. She's playing the long con and I
do remember and he only said he only
sent it to Rose, right? Yeah. Well,
that's what he
said. They back to the future did. Okay,
dude. I I just I just want to know how
he's going to explain to these people
that this happened. This person says
Pepe laugh in 2023. Do they know Do they
know why it's funny that is in 2023?
Name of the file. They put her first
name in the file name.
Bro, where's the message of me sending
her the thing? This is I didn't know
this would be hearsay. I didn't know
what the this
is. Wait, no, no, no. This is uh this is
evidence in support of her saying that
this this happened. By the way, I will
say if you remember back to like rap
reviews when Destiny did rap reviews
when it came down to like a he said she
said, let's say in this case, okay, for
example, in this case, people say um
she's saying you sent me the videos. Oh,
that's like that that's hearsay because
she says you also deleted the logs or
the links to to you sending the videos,
right? Okay. Well, what's Destiny's
number one thing when it's a when it's a
review? Okay, he's doing a review and he
decides, okay, it's a he said, she said.
I need some evidence. You know what I
would expect? Messages to friends is
always the first one. Did she message
the friends and say what happened? Are
is there is there some record of her
believing that it was like an assault on
the night of? Here's the here's the
exact circumstantial evidence that he
always brings up. Hey, when this
happened, right? When this happened.
It's contemporary is a good good word
for it. Contemporaneous logs. Yes.
Contemporaneous evidence. We have
timespecific evidence that shows that
this happened, right? That they're not
making it up. They're not just, you
know, changing their mind after the
fact. Contemporaneous evidence that
shows that this this happened. And he's
going, "Wait, wait, wait. They don't
have the logs of me." That's actually
what she said in her declaration that
she didn't have logs of you sending the
video because you deleted them.
That's entire. That's exactly what she
said. And she said, "I have vlogs of me
telling a friend that he had sent these
videos and I
names." By the way, I I will say, by the
way,
I No. Nope. I'm not saying anything
else. This
is This is obviously exactly what she
said she had. This is obviously exactly
what she said she had. This the whole
point of this is that Destiny is saying
there's no proof of the Cardi thing.
This now gives evidence that they should
look for these things in discovery that
yeah, some of this stuff should be
subpoenaed. Hey, we should actually look
for
it. Why wouldn't that person who says
that he send the link just send the
Discord log that has the link to the
video? Because he deleted all of their
logs. Are you Yeah, you are Decisis. I
see your name. Yeah, you are a
um listen, I think you're probably about
to come from the public humiliation
you're engaging in, right? You're you're
in this humiliation ritual. You're doing
it to yourself. You're saying things in
the chat. So, I'll let you finish. I
won't I won't time you out. I'll just
let you finish coming. You can keep
humiliating
yourself. What do
we Now he's acting incredulous because
he needs DJs to be incredulous, right?
This is, by the way, this is the exact
exact evidence that she said she had
that I said, "Oh, if she has that
contemporaneous evidence, that is a
total game changer." Total game changer,
right? And I believe he said, "This
evidence couldn't possibly exist. She's
lying." I think that's I'm pretty sure
that's what he
said. Uh, even if she doesn't have the
video anymore, how the hell does he
explain that she knew about this two
years ago? That's a fantastic question.
Shut it down. That's a fantastic
question that anybody who's not
completely cognitively would also ask.
So, congratulations on not having it in
your brain.
Okay. You can sometimes line here say in
support interlock applications. What? I
don't know if that has to do anything.
She the this declarant claimed that she
had logs of me supposedly sending her
these things despite the fact I deleted
them to hide them. No, she never claimed
that actually. She literally never Oh,
he's just he's just actually making
things up now. She didn't claim that.
She didn't claim that. Can somebody grab
me a time stamp? I don't know if Ry is
still around. Somebody grab me a time
stamp of him going through the Abbey
Declaration. Let's just watch him cover
the Abbey
Declaration because he should know from
reading that declaration because I
certainly read it and wasn't a total
reading it,
right? This is what she said she had was
contemporaneous logs telling a friend
about these these videos.
So why not just post
that? There's also a message missing in
the middle of those two. It's grayed out
as the same color. Oh, you're right. And
so that's not redacted. That's just um
that's just doctorred cuz they're hiding
stuff here. If they wanted to hide
something here, they should redact it.
It should be redacted like in these
black boxes, not
doctorred. Okay.
I'm just waiting for any argument about
why there would be contemporaneous
evidence of you saying of you sending
these things in
2023. That's I would just love to
know. I'm sure at some point we'll
figure it out, right?
He's
literally Okay, if you're a DGR, you
have to look at this silence and be
like, "What the is?" Wait, I thought we
were winning, buddy. Buddy, we were
winning. I thought we were w Aren't we
doing good? I thought we were doing so
good. Wait, what are you Why are you
totally silent right now?
Well,
well.
Huh? Brother, you got to do better. You
got to do better than
this. Is he good? Anything else open?
Nothing.
All
right. Does he not want to go f Wait,
would he not want to go find out what
Abby said? Or wouldn't Wouldn't he just
said, "Oh, didn't she say she had logs
of me? Wouldn't you want to go open up
Aby's
declaration? What's What's going on,
buddy? Are you
okay?" Oh, connections. Oh god, I feel
like I'm feverish. I feel like I have a
fever.
I'm suddenly flushed. Okay, I don't want
to spoil connections for myself. He's
going to play connections. I'm not
spoiling
connections. That's very
funny. That is very funny. Oh my
goodness. Okay, we have to go find Hold
on. I I wish Where's my Where are my
linkers at? Is it just cuz we're on late
that we got no linkers ready to fight
for the cause? This is up. I have to go
find my own
links. Hold on. I'll do it cuz cuz why
not? Last night on
Destiny. Oh. Uh, no. Not that one.
That's the wrong one. That one. Yeah.
Yeah.
Oh,
hello. Oh, hello.
The the whoever Abby would be this with
the screen name Abby MC. Ah, yes. Oh,
who did that? Spruce, thank you for the
gifted sub. Thank you. Thank you.
Hold on. She won't respond. Still trying
to date her and then he's like
threatening to kill himself and then
he's like trying to send like he's like,
"Okay, this is their big meme."
Okay, so one thing to keep in mind is
the um Okay, I'm saying something we've
known. There are four causes of action
listed on the initial complaint. Uh you
have Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, hold
on. I don't I didn't grab the time stamp
here. My bad. So the time
stamp
here in November 2023 after the
statute's effective date C exhibit 22
decoration of C. Thus the court has
subject under restriction and plaint
likely to success on one merit of the
party claim. So it's an important one
because this will bring the alleged
stuff entering into the statute. Is
thisation public?
Okay, it's a public one. Okay, let's
see. Let's see what he says. Let's see.
Let's just see how it goes. Revealing
information about themselves. I don't
understand how people keep doing this.
Okay.
Okay. Let's go. I'm over the age of 18
and commented to write test oath. This
is my screen name as IBMC. Some people
might know who this is. Um
when you publicly confirmed who it was,
you mean like hours before this? I have
personal knowledge of the matters here
and if called to testify this matter, I
could confidently testify as to the
facts contained in the affidavit. I
first connected with uh overt dummy.
Thank you for the gift itself. Thank
you. Thank you.
I should wait for the sound effect to
come up, but thank
you3 discord and other platforms on
September. So, here's um and Destiny
does not necessarily dispute this. Okay,
so that's important to know. March 2023
is after Cardi comes into effect. They
didn't know each other. He had no way to
send her videos or even talk to her
before March of 2023. Anything he had
sent her would be coming under the the
effect of Cardi. Cardi was already
passed. Third, he went to Miami, hung
out, b did stuff. I don't know if I
should say anything about that, but
whatever.
Um, hold on. Somebody said, "Why would
the new party affect this lawsuit?
Wouldn't she be the one to have to say
you're in a new law? Like, if I steal
something?" Um, well, because she's
providing an affidavit to try to um show
that uh the original claim in this
lawsuit happened within the date range.
The problem is that they're trying to
sue me in federal court because they're
saying that an action that I did was
illegal under a law that only came into
effect, I think, like a year or so or
whatever, after the alleged action. And
the issue is that if that is the case,
then that federal cause of action
wouldn't apply. And because they cited
one federal cause of action and three
state causes of action, if the federal
cause of action is dismissed because the
court lacks subject matter jurisdiction
because there would be no federal claim,
just three state claims, then the whole
case basically gets ejected. So the
issue is is since that one doesn't fit,
and they know that it doesn't fit, uh
they lied in their initial filing on the
date that that video had allegedly been
they lied about the date. I'm sure they
know that they lied about the date. Uh
now they're like basically desperately
scrging around trying to define somebody
else who like okay well was there video
here blah blah blah and so even though
this person was never a part of the
original complaint has never been
referenced before mentioned before now
like at this like at the twilight hours
they have found somebody who is saying
oh well actually I received this video
all he does is the twilight hours the
person might not have messaged them
right away you have no idea about the
time course of this at all he's just
totally speculating on November of 2023
or whatever
um on or about November 3rd 2023 Destiny
shared a Google Drive link to sexually a
video. I Why does he burp so much now? I
don't remember him being like this
before. Um, he started to imitate Kelly
Jean's mannerisms because Kelly Jean
owns him. So, he started imitating Kelly
Jean's mannerisms, including burping.
Denise the plaintiff on here. I've seen
her post on Instagram here. There's also
a declaration about another person about
Cherry, which is Are you going to skip
over that they lied? Uh, I don't know if
they lied or that up. He's saying they
lied. I don't know if they lied or that
up. They did in their initial um what do
you call it their initial complaint they
had another piece in the complaint that
said we have another person who's
talking to us who has who received this
video just like 3 months ago or
something or like 6 months ago right so
they said there was another person they
were trying to get to make a
comment but he didn't point that out. So
this was also not part of this complaint
or a part of this case at all
whatsoever. I have no idea why that's
brought up here. Yeah, this shouldn't
have been included. Declarations about
other Google Drive links. Um, wait, did
he just Wait, did he just skip over this
instead of which is who's also not part
of hold on or
whatever. Um, about November 3rd, 2023.
Destiny shared a Google Drive link to a
video. Um, I recognize the plaintiff on
here. I've seen her post on Instagram
here.
Okay. There's also a declaration about
uh another person about Cherry, which is
who's also not part of this complaint or
part of this. Oh, so he just didn't pay
attention to read. He literally said,
"Oh, this has to" But that's not what
happened, right? That's sorry. He didn't
read the first sentence is about at all
whatsoever. I have no idea why that's
brought up here. Uh the Cherishin thing
shouldn't be referenced, but he got
asked mad about the fact that something
that's outside of this case was
mentioned and he didn't read that
sentence. The first thing is on about
November 3rd, 2023, I messaged a friend
of mine and told him that Destiny had
sent me the above mentioned explicit
video of himself and another woman and
that I recognized the woman as the
streamer Pixie. I also told my friend
that Destiny sent me another video of
him and another streamer that I
recognized. Okay. I have retained in my
possession a copy of the messages to my
friend. That's what it says here. Um,
decorations about other Google Drive
links. Uh, I recently reviewed my
Discord account and realized that
Destiny deleted all of his direct
messages to me on this the Discord
platform, including the sharing of the
video of Pixie. I retained copies of all
of my messages to Destiny as well as my
messages to other people about his
non-consensual sharing of explicit
videos.
Uh, Accelerati in here it says that it's
audio only, black screen audio only. Um,
I recently reviewed my Discord account
and realized that I deleted all of his
direct messages to me on the Discord
platform, including uh sharing many
videos of Pixie. I have retained copies
of all my messages to Destiny as well as
my messages other people about his
non-consensual. Yeah. Oh, so he did read
this part. So he either totally forgot
again very very, you know, very EP boy,
very EP
boy, right?
But you can see here, nowhere does Abby
say I have evidence of Destiny sending
me the video, right? Sorry. Like um like
I don't have direct evidence of Destiny
sending I didn't save those logs. She
literally says she doesn't have those
logs sharing videos. I do not want my
identity publicly revealed since I have
recently discovered that he also shared
videos of himself and me with other
people without my consent just like he
did. So a lot of stuff that's not I
wonder when she found that out. I wonder
if that changed her view of this whole
situation possibly. Huh.
that. So, just to be clear, keeps
records for the court according to him.
Yeah, who knows? I don't know why those
records would be accepted as like the
the actual like you can't just have a
record that's in HTML or JSON where you
could just delete any any negative
messages and say that's a record. That's
insane. Uh, I do not have want to have
my identity publicly revealed since I've
recently discovered that Destiny shared
explicit videos of himself and me with
other people without my consent just
like he did to Pixie and these other
women. And I believe she has sent a like
a demand letter um asking Destiny for a
settlement or that she'll see him in
court.
Right. So, it's probably why he's so
anxious about this in general. Not the
subject matter of the complaint that has
nothing to do with this case. So, I
don't even know if I if we end up
responding to any of this because it's,
you know, whatever. But, so this is
their Twilight Hours person that they
brought in for this. Ideally, there
would be some kind of evidence of any of
the claims here.
Um, I there is don't know what I'll say
until they rule on this preliminary
injection, but let me just say that
there is absolutely no evidence of any
of this
preliminary injection. But let me just
say that there's he's literally circling
the paragraph of what they I have
retained in my position a copy of the
messages to my friend. He's circling the
paragraph and saying there is no
evidence of this. There is no evidence
of this. There is no evidence of this. I
Is he trying to cast a spell? Is he
trying to wish that that were so?
There's absolutely no evidence of any of
this, but who knows? You know, I could
be lying or I could be crazy.
I probably lead to the former.
Um, so that's So this is the a
declaration of a person. We don't know
who this is though. It's just Abby MC.
Thankfully, they filed a seno under
protective order.
Is there any actual evidence that you
shared it after that date or is it just
her saying that there is? Uh, it's just
her statement. That's it.
So, this was his major problem was that
there was no contemporaneous evidence at
all. Thus, the court has subject matter
jurisdiction and plaintiff has
demonstrated a likelihood of success on
the merits of her. Okay. So, he might
not have been aware because he decided
he wasn't going to read the inconvenient
paragraph. Now whether or not you
believe that that's because he wanted
that be that's because he just was like
uncomfortable whether no matter what you
believe
here I'm pretty sure oh there's some
other ah
oh we'll see um
yeah it I'm going to say it
no don't I'm not going to say it. Never
mind. Never mind. I'll see what I should
or shouldn't
say. Okay, I'll just
say perhaps perhaps there's a
reason perhaps there's a reason why when
he mouses over this paragraph and seeing
somebody's name in it, he actually
doesn't want to read anything more there
and wants to move
on. Very
interesting. Very interesting.
Perhaps there's a reason that
like, you know, perhaps there's a reason
he was like calling people crazy and
then he shut the up about
them. What do you guys think? Why would
he go from calling somebody crazy to
going, "Oh, I don't comment on them
anymore."
Huh? I
h I wonder why that might be.
Just speculation. I don't know anything
special. It's just
speculation. Very
interesting. I have no inside
information. I'm just speculating on
patterns that seem interesting. I'm
something of a noticer. That's what they
call me. Old noticing gym over here.
Okay. We noticing things sometimes.
Bro, you are Destiny's Pazookas. Nice.
Well, Pazookas is a genius. So, if
that's what's happening, we love to see
it.
Okay. Okay. I think that's that's it. We
covered We got all of it. We got all of
it, guys. We got Oh, we got
Oh, listen. We're hoping that by the end
of this trial, all right, I'm going to
move up. I'm going to leaprog Hassan and
maybe even leaprog a live stream fail.
Okay. I want to make it further up. We
got to get higher. We have to get higher
up. All right. In his
priority. All right. That was fun, guys.
I enjoyed I enjoyed I enjoyed. Oh, I
didn't see any of my redeems. Assad is
bad. My bad, guys. I didn't see that
earlier. Assad is
bad. Now it's time for Darius Mercury
cap. I don't know if I'm gonna keep
doing that, dude. That's just
gh. It's just so with Darius being like
a really bad person. I don't know. This
just sucks, dude. It just really sucks.
That's about That's like all you can
say, right? This just sucks. Just like a
dude, dude doing
things. You know how it
is, bro? Why is Twitch just offering me
nothing but like streamers to raid
the And it doesn't even show me like
there's one person I would actually raid
on Twitch and they don't show up on my
actual like suggested Twitch
raids. That's so odd. Anyway, it was
bizarre.
Okay, got that one lined up. Okay, guys.
I'm out of here. Have a good night. I'll
be back
tomorrow. JT talk smug emote when? I'm
not totally sure. Okay. I will send you.
If you're if you're one of the gay dudes
in chat, you're going to be very tickled
at who we're rating.
Okay. You're a gay dude in chat, you're
going to love it. If you're not a gay
dude, if you're a straight dude, you
might not love it as much. So, have a
good one,
guys. We'll see y'all later. We'll see
y'all
later. Have a good night. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Good night.
Good night. Bye-bye.